easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy
ich weiß nicht warum aber wie war es dazu dass ich einfach ein paar mal
späme wer könnte auch einfach sagen
ist ja was ganz und gar nicht easy ist also darüber zu reden auf youtube battlefield 20
42 ich habe ein video aufgenommen 28 minuten wo ich mich voll über das game ausgelassen
habe oder habe ich mir das video noch mal angehört und ich dachte mir so eigentlich
stimmt das alles was du sagst aber man muss das auf youtube einfach anders verpacken weil
sonst die ganzen ultra fans wieder komplett eskalieren naja das auch das auch wobei da
habe ich ja schon zugestimmt ich muss auch leute da kommen wir nicht drum herum ich muss noch zwei
ea sellout videos machen keine chance leider ich weiß auch nicht warum ich dazu gesagt habe
ich muss noch zwei ea sellout videos machen was ziemlich doof ist weil ich finde das game so wie
es jetzt ist nicht gut weil einfach komplett unfertig battlefield ist also dass das dem
jetzigen zustand das ist einfach so als hätte man es mitten aus der entwicklung gerissen und
veröffentlicht anders kann man das nicht beschreiben denke ich so wie ich wie ein kind was keine ahnung im sechsten monat rausflutscht
so wie ich wie ein kind was keine ahnung im sechsten monat rausflutscht
es ist einfach nicht fertig der nächste hetsam stream wir hatten doch erst ein hatten wir nicht
letzte woche oder vorletzte woche ein als die ihr rechenzentrum in den usa aufgemacht haben noch zwei
weitere videos über portal nee nee nee so einfach ist es leider nicht wir haben uns darauf geeinigt
drei verschiedene videos ich weiß nicht könnte man fragen zu portal würde ich easy noch zwei
stück machen die strongs leute wollten das save früher rausbringen ja definitiv
liegt das an den strongs leuten ich wüsste auch nicht an was sonst übrigens ich habe was
rausgefunden vielleicht bringt das ja einem von euch was ich erzähle euch das jetzt mal und zwar
heute mal bei entspannungs stream ich werde heute kein battlefield spielen und ich werde mich auch
nicht großartig aufregen vielleicht rede ich ein bisschen über battlefield auf oder so mal gucken
aber ich vielleicht gibt es vielleicht gibt es da auch tolle videos zu keine ahnung aber was
ich rausgefunden habe ist wenn ich kopfweh habe oder
anfange kopfweh zu bekommen muss ich also um dagegen zu werden muss ich folgendes machen ich
muss die hände nehmen also hände nehmen und so ineinander ineinander verschränken so hier als
quasi die finger durcheinander machen dann muss ich das nehmen und quasi ich hinten an kopf halten
und dann drücke ich mit den händen von hinten gegen den kopf und mit dem kopf quasi so nach
hinten an die hände so also so dass man kommt mit dem kopf an die hände und mit dem kopf so dass man
quasi komplett nackenmuskeln kopf schultern und das alles braucht dafür um dagegen zu drücken
und wenn ich das dann so mal mache so eine irgendwie heißt话 sekunden lang dann ist
das fast wieder instant weg das richtig nice wir können wir als ihr blut oder das können wir nicht
also wir können das schon aber das machen wir nicht was ist denn aus es ist morgen ist morgen
nicht Black Friday?
Ist morgen nicht Black Friday?
Dann machst du 24.7.
Ja, dann habe ich dann bald
Schultern wie der Giga-Chat.
Oder wie heißt dieser Typ?
Giga-Chat.
Ach, nächste Woche?
Na, es ist ja
mittlerweile eh gefühlt
das gesamte Jahr Black Friday.
Lieferkrise.
Wo sich der Black Friday
trotzdem lohnen konnte?
Haben wir eine Lieferkrise?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Haben wir eigentlich in irgendwas keine Krise?
Ich meine,
wir haben Corona,
wir haben New World,
wir haben Battlefield 2042,
wir haben Chipmangel,
Grafikkartenpreise.
Es ist ja überall
Krise gerade.
Also das ist ja gerade, was ist denn da los?
Postboten kurz
vor dem Burnout.
Wann ist der Black Friday?
29. nächstes Jahr.
Nächstes, äh, nicht nächstes, was?
Ich erzähle manchmal unsinniges Zeug.
Nächste Woche.
Nicht nächstes Jahr.
Und auch erst nächste Woche.
Warum ist der 29.
ein Friday?
Ach vom 19. bis 29.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, was es war.
Warum ist?
Warum ist der?
Warum ist der 29.
Freitag?
Ich traue es dem Microsoft Kalender zu,
dass das nicht nicht funktioniert.
Also doch morgen.
Ja, doch morgen.
Ich habe wieder vorher eine lustige News gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Heise war.
Hier, das da.
Scaleway kennt man ja vom Namen her.
Und Gaia-X sollte diese europäische,
ich weiß es nicht genau,
diese europäische Cloud-Geschichte sein,
wo man sich quasi, steht hier glaube ich,
unabhängig machen wollte von großen Cloud-Anbietern in den USA.
Und die haben jetzt gesagt,
leckt mich, ich hau ab,
hab keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Jetzt mal im Ernst.
Hat irgendjemand damit gerechnet,
dass da was rauskommt?
Dass das irgendwie, dass wir was auf die Reihe kriegen?
Es ist eigentlich bitter.
Man geht ja schon standardmäßig mittlerweile von aus,
dass sowas nichts wird.
Aber welche?
Ich überlege gerade, welche IT-Projekte haben wir denn gut hinbekommen?
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Gesundheitskarte hat nicht richtig funktioniert mit dem Ausweis.
Es will immer noch kein Mensch benutzen.
E-Post und Dingsbums Geschiss wollte keiner.
Ähm.
Für unsere Corona-Apps war gar nicht zu schweigen, ja?
So, das war ja auch nix.
Was hatten wir denn sonst noch Schönes?
Hat da irgendwas funktioniert?
Lass mal, jetzt sag mal ernsthaft, fällt euch irgendwas ein?
Digital, Affirische, ja, das ist alles.
Doch, doch, eins muss ich sagen, das funktioniert,
das ist der Deutsche Wetterdienst.
Das klappt tatsächlich.
Aber den gibt's ja auch schon eine Weile.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ähm, hauptsache, hauptsache in jedem Ausweis müssen jetzt Fingerabdrücke rein.
Oh Leute, mir fällt was ein, mein Auslauf, mein Ausweis läuft ab.
Ich muss meinen Ausweis noch verlängern lassen.
Omg.
D-Mail, das gibt's doch gar nicht mehr, das haben die doch eingestellt.
Es gab D-Mail, es gab D-Mail und, was, was war das, E-Postbrief oder so?
Es gab noch zwei verschiedene, äh, Konkurrierende und, äh, ich kenn jemanden, der war, also,
ich kenn einen von der Arbeit, der hat, äh, bei, entweder D-Mail oder E-Post, ich weiß es nicht,
eins von beiden gearbeitet und hat auch mal erzählt, was das für eine Shitshow war.
Balls in die Finger im System, ja.
Ja, meine China-Chinesen-Sachen kamen auch richtig pünktlich an, kann man sich nicht,
kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Ja, ich bin, ich bin, ich bin, nee, so übertrieben müde bin ich nicht, aber hey, Leute, guckt mal auf die Uhr.
Bald ist Bett, gell.
Wunder, dass ich müde kling.
Fehlt nur noch Wasser und, naja, in manchen Teilen der Welt,
das ist ja schon Krise.
Aber ich hab doch irgendwas überlesen am Anfang, oder?
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs gestern, die ich, äh, übersehen hab,
während ich mich da über Battlefield aufgeregt hab.
Ja, morgen ist Battlefield 2042 Release, ich sag euch.
Daku, danke für den Sub, falls ihr ihn nicht gesehen habt.
21 Monate, Massive, da hast du jetzt ja hier schon den, den Poggers-Keks,
den mit goldener Kette.
Am Morgen werden dann auch die Letzten sehen, in welchem schrecklichen Zustand das Spiel ist.
Wobei, ich, wobei, der Day-One-Patch wird ja alles lösen, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Wollt kurz was trinken.
Was ist eigentlich mit so AAA-Games los?
Erst kommt New World raus, hat jeden Tag einen neuen Glitch.
Battlefield, komplett im Arsch.
Also viele AAA-Games sind doch mittlerweile eigentlich nur so ein Schatten ihrer selbst.
Ich glaube, es lohnt sich gar nicht mehr, am Battlefield-Portal-Bilder weiterzumachen.
Also ernsthaft, ähm,
ich glaube,
das Game wird die übelste Todgeburt.
Weil,
das mag ja alles sein,
dass man, also es gibt ja Leute, die sagen,
jaja, die patchen das noch alles gut, Battlefield 4 war auch nice und so.
Aber wie gesagt, Battlefield 4 hat, äh,
einen guten Kern gehabt, den sehe ich bei Battlefield 2042 nicht.
Und,
selbst, wenn die das patchen,
es hat, das, das ist,
ja auch für DICE nicht, äh,
erstrebenswert, oder, oder, EA,
Money-Technik, nicht, äh, nicht anzustreben.
Quasi, wenn alle Spieler schon weggerannt sind, das zu fixen, weil,
naja, die Spieler kommen nicht wieder.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht.
Halo soll angeblich ziemlich gut sein.
Also,
vielleicht soll ich mich nicht, vielleicht soll ich mich,
soll ich sagen, die Trip, was ist mit den AAA, AAA-Games von EA los, oder,
Bethesda, oder sonst was, aber,
Microsoft kriegt's ja in letzter Zeit tatsächlich ganz gut hin.
Ich hatte übrigens jemand per Mail angeschrieben,
ich glaube, der war gestern hier auch im Stream,
ob ich ihnen nicht, äh, gegen Bezahlung, sinngemäß,
äh, ein Battlefield Portal
äh, Spielmodus bauen könnte.
Und da hab ich gesagt, nee, nee, da müsst ihr mich nicht für bezahlen.
und da hab ich gesagt, nee, nee, da müsst ihr mich nicht für bezahlen.
Wenn er, der muss halt mal genau erklären, was er haben will.
Vielleicht bauen wir das sogar im Stream.
Weil, dann hab ich einfach, dann hab ich, äh,
interessanten Content, der auch
interessanten Content, der auch irgendwas,
irgendwas nutzt, im Endeffekt.
Geschäftsidee.
Mich wundert's, was das für Geschäftsidee ist.
Wusstet ihr,
wusstet ihr, weil du gerade gesagt hast, Geschäftsidee,
wusstet ihr, dass es Leute gibt, die quasi
wusstet ihr, dass es Leute gibt, die quasi monatlich davon leben können,
in denen sie, und ich meine das wirklich nicht negativ,
auch wenn ich das jetzt ein bisschen höre, als mache ich mich darüber lustig,
nee, nee, ich finde das so interessant,
die monatlich davon leben können,
die von Leuten optimieren.
Das war mir komplett neu.
Bald können sie
ihre Dienst auf Battlefield 2042
ausweiten.
Also, wenn was Optimierung
braucht, dann Battlefield 2042.
Ja, ich war selbst sehr überrascht,
dass es
sowas gibt, aber ja, das gibt's.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er nur Warzone
macht, aber zu
99% ist das Warzone.
Sieht man auch bei ihm auf Twitter.
Das hat mich echt gewundert.
Remaster ist auch abfuck, ja.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt,
wann kommt, wann kommt,
wann kommt Witcher Season 2
Dezember, gell?
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch abfuck.
Wobei,
die erste, also ich fand die erste Staffel
jetzt nicht umwerfend, aber die war jetzt
auch nicht zu vergleichen mit irgendwie
Warcraft 3 Reforged
von der Qualität her, das war schon in Ordnung.
Aber ist sicherlich nicht mein Serienhighlight.
Ähm, kommt jetzt nicht bald auch
Amazon hier, äh, Wheel of Time?
Wann startet das denn?
Ist es nicht auch irgendwann jetzt?
Start? Launch?
Ach, morgen! Interessant.
Oh, das werden die so krass
verkackt haben. Das werden die bestimmt
hardcore verkacken.
Ähm, was wäre ein guter Salepreis
für Battlefield 2040?
Also mal ganz im Ernst.
Im aktuellen Zustand, wie das Game
ist, wenn du nicht
gerade
Heli-begeisterter bist, der die neue
Heli-Physik mag, ich würde mir das Spiel
nicht kaufen. Du hast keinen Spaß
da dran, also das lohnt sich gar nicht.
Es ist sinnvoll, Games, die
an sich spaßig sind,
aber die man jetzt vielleicht nicht so
als Main-Game eine Weile spielen will,
sollte man, die im Sale
zu kaufen, aber ein Game, was sich permanent
abfuckt, willst du dir doch eigentlich gar nicht kaufen.
Die müssten nicht im aktuellen Zustand
jetzt mal, jetzt mal wirklich
Real Talk, wie man da so schön sagt,
die müssten dich im aktuellen Zustand
eigentlich dafür bezahlen, dass du das spielst
und für die
Beta-Tester bist. Also normalerweise
bezahlt man Leute für sowas, was da gerade
abgeht.
Ich meine, ihr habt es doch gestern im Stream gesehen, wir hatten
nicht eine Runde ohne irgendwelche
Game-Breaking-Bugs.
Manche waren so schlimm, dass wir die Runde verlassen mussten.
Äh, tatsächlich, ja.
Ich hab gehört, dass
Forza Horizon, was ist das jetzt? 5?
Kann das sein, dass wir bei 5 sind?
Ich verfolge das nicht so.
Rennspiele sind nicht meins.
Ich hab gehört, die haben den
Teams-Call-Ton als
Hupe.
Stell euch mal so eine Hupe vor, Alter.
Da machst du die Leute aber verrückt.
Ich glaube, auf die Hupe reagieren die Leute
mehr als auf echte Hupen.
Hit-Registration aus der
Hölle, ja. Kennst du das hier?
Hab ich gestern mal
kurz reingeguckt, ja.
Ja, wobei es sich ein bisschen viel
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt
nur die ersten 5 Minuten mir angeguckt.
Er reitet ein bisschen viel
auf Bugs rum. Wie gesagt,
ich hab's ja gerade am Anfang gesagt, ich will das nicht
schönreden. Das Game ist in absolut
grausamem Zustand.
Aber Battlefield 2042 hat
deutlich grundlegendere Probleme als
die Bugs. Das ist
nämlich im Kern, und das ist
nix, was du mit Bugs fixen kannst,
ein
noch ein Abziehbild
von Battlefield ist.
Jetzt mal wieder Stellenanzeigen-Video.
Ja, wird echt mal wieder Zeit, ne?
Ja.
Ich versteh's auch nicht.
Mir hat die Beta...
Also, ich weiß nicht genau, woran's liegt.
Mal davon abgesehen, dass man gefühlt
langsamer rennt und die Waffen nicht hitten, ja.
Aber das Gameplay in der Beta
hat mir um Längen
besser gefallen.
Das war irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen,
schneller, direkter,
es ging ordentlich was rein,
du wurdest nicht von jedem
aus allen Winkeln
bullshitted mit irgendwas.
Deswegen, ich warte mal ab.
Ich hab ja ein Video heute aufgenommen, wo ich das Spiel echt
ziemlich hart rangenommen hab.
Gachi-Bass.
Aber, das lad ich nicht hoch.
Wollt ihr das Video sehen?
Ich kann euch das Video im Stream zeigen.
Aber ich lad's nicht auf YouTube hoch, weil das war
das, ähm,
das war ein bisschen hart und ich denke, manches hätte ich
besser erklären können.
Wollt ihr das, da gucken wir uns das gleich,
da gucken wir uns das gleich noch zusammen an.
Also quasi unreleasedes
Video-Footage.
Fuck.
Oder Not Pock.
Werden wir dann sehen, ne?
Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich merken, warum ich das nicht hochladen kann.
Ich muss das alles ein bisschen besser erklären.
Aber nicht wie der Rackordner liegen.
Oh je, oh je.
Ups, wo ist das?
Kann das mal aufhören?
Nicht den Rackordner liegen.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Den Rackordner zu leaken ist keine gute Idee.
Die meisten von euch fragen sich wahrscheinlich
jetzt, was ist der Rackordner-Leak
und macht euch nichts draus. Ihr müsst das nicht wissen.
Wasch, ich war schnell.
Ich will im Video löschen.
So hab ich da geguckt.
Legit.
Als ich das geleakt hab.
So.
Dachte, Max wollte keine Spiele
programmieren.
Spielmodi im Logik-Editor ist ja
was anderes.
Das war auch richtig enttäuschend.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach.
Die machen wohl irgendwelche Config-Dateien-Tweaks
oder sonst wie. Wie gesagt, mich hat's auch
gewundert, dass es Leute gibt, die damit Geld
verdienen.
Die Spiele-Settings von anderen Leuten zu optimieren.
Aber gibt es, und wenn man damit was verdienen kann,
ist doch nice.
Wer sonst zockt noch Warzone? Oh, ziemlich viele.
Gibt es ne, gibt es ne, ne, ne, Spieler?
Ich glaub, die haben keine Statistik, ne?
Für Warzone-Player-Account.
Ja, das ist ja immer Bullshit-Marketing-Meldungen.
So Daily interessiert mich.
Nee, die wissen's nicht.
Es ist das schlechteste Battlefield, was es bisher gegeben hat.
Alles meiner Meinung nach, ja, aber ich spiel Battlefield schon eine ganze Weile und ich denke, ich hab da einen ganz guten Überblick und ich bin der Ansicht, es ist, wie gesagt, nicht nur verbuggt, das Fuck, das ist das eine, es hat aber auch keinen guten Kern.
Und das hatten bisher fast alle Battlefields.
Selbst Hardline.
Ja.
Bleibt dir nix anderes da übrig.
Also wenn du wirklich Battlefield-Fan bist und Battlefield magst, so wie Battlefield halt ist.
Wärst du wahrscheinlich mit 2042 nicht glücklich.
Ich fand Hardline auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Hardline haben halt die guten Spielmodi gefehlt.
Ja, leider ist Orbital tatsächlich die beste Map.
Das sagt schon alles.
Ja, egal.
Wie sieht es denn aus mit der Börse?
Läuft das? Nee.
Ich sag, ich sag ja immer wieder, ich muss mich unbedingt drum kümmern, sonst ist bald Geld, Geld weg.
Leute, zum Thema Geld weg.
Ich hab jetzt von den Stadtwerke, hab ich jetzt, ja doch, Stadtwerke, hab ich jetzt einen Brief bekommen, dass ich anstatt 100 ungefähr, also gerundet, 120 Euro im Monat, im Monat Gas für die Heizung bezahlen muss, anstatt 120 Euro muss ich 235 Euro bezahlen.
Das sind 95% mehr.
Belegt euch das mal.
Also ich mein, 5% mehr ist ja schon ordentlich, aber 95% mehr?
Soll ich mir demnächst Brennholz holen, wobei Holz ist auch teuer.
Jetzt kann doch nicht der Ernst sein.
Und bei mir ist es ja so, ich mein, ich kann das ja glücklicherweise alles noch bezahlen, ja.
Was machen denn Leute, die nicht so viel Kohle auf der hohen Kante haben?
Gehen die dann?
Bleiben die dann im Bett?
Zahlst du auch viel?
Wie viel Strom?
Das weiß ich grad aus dem Kopf nicht, wie viel das ist.
Oh je, oh je, deutsche Twitter-Trends, ich klick da nicht drauf.
Legalisierung kommt, nice, haben sie es geschafft?
So, ich stell's mal kurz angucken.
420, Alter!
Haben sie es hingekriegt, ja.
Das ist ja eine der Sachen, wo ich auch dafür war.
Allerdings, auf der anderen Seite ist es auch im großen Gesamtbild ziemlich unwichtig.
Also es gibt doch, es gibt, mit Sicherheit.
Ähm, aber so schwerwiegendere Probleme, die man angehen musste.
Allerdings ist vielleicht manches damit einfacher zu ertragen, keine Ahnung.
Ich muss aber dazu sagen, es hört sich jetzt vielleicht so an, als bin ich hier der Ultra-Kiffer oder so.
Nee, bin ich nicht.
Aber ich find's trotzdem gut, dass das legalisiert wird.
Ich hab noch einen Server in der Wohnung stehen und das heizt nicht mein ganzes Haus hier.
Ich hab heute auch wieder, wo du grad sagst, Schwarzarbeit, nein, mach ich nicht, ja.
Muss ich immer davor sagen, sonst kommt noch einer und sagt, oh der Max hier, geh dann zum Finanzamt.
Hier, guck mal, der Max, nein, mach ich nicht.
Aber ich hab heute wieder meine Gehaltsabrechnung bekommen und hab festgestellt, wie viel von dem, was eigentlich mein Arbeitgeber bezahlt, nicht bei mir ankommt.
Ja, ihr könnt machen, was ihr wollt.
So, was wollte ich denn jetzt noch sagen?
Wollen wir uns das Video angucken?
Wir gucken dann, wir gucken da noch ein bisschen Amazon-Zeusch, was irgendwelche Smart-Home-Sachen gibt.
Aber ich, wie gesagt, ich hab euch gefragt, ihr habt gesagt, ihr wollt's gucken.
Dann...
Soll ich nicht länger hinhalten, wir gucken das gleich.
Ähm, übrigens, einfach nur, weil's so schön ist, ich muss das, ich muss das jedes, jeden Tag zeigen.
Ich, ich freu mich da drüber, weil das auch sowas ist, weil ich gesagt hab, das geht voll in die Hose.
Und gerade die, die Ultra-Fanboys wieder, ähm, so nach dem Motto, es gab ja wirklich, also ernsthaft, ich hab das letztens auf Twitter gepostet.
Also, da gab es wieder Leute, die geschrieben haben, Max, das ist doch vollkommen normal für einen neuen MMO-Start.
Also, man kann sich alles irgendwie so hindrehen.
Wisst ihr, was mein Lieblingsargument ist, warum, wenn jemand sagt, Battlefield 2042 ist verbackte Kacke?
Mein Lieblingsargument ist, wenn die Leute dann sagen, ja, Max, jeder Battlefield-Lounge ist doch verbackt.
Was ist das denn für ein...
Dieses Argument, jeder Battlefield-Lounge ist verkackt, ziemlich schlecht ist, weil nur, weil bisher jeder Battlefield-Lounge verkackt war,
könnte man ja was draus lernen und diesen Battlefield-Lounge nicht verkackt machen.
Das ist ja mal das Erste.
Also, du könntest einfach dafür sorgen, dass der nicht verkackt ist.
Und, äh, außerdem macht's das ja, macht's das ja in keinster Weise besser.
Was, was ist der tiefste Peak bei New World?
Ja, so heute, würde ich sagen, gestern.
Im Prinzip eigentlich immer...
Oh, ne, guck mal, heute ist es wieder ein bisschen hochge...
Äh...
18.000 nachts.
Aber ich glaub, hier waren Server-Wartungsarbeiten, ne, wobei, kann nicht sein.
25.000, 16.000, aber ich glaub, hier waren wirklich Wartungsarbeiten.
Ja, das sind immer Wartungsarbeiten, glaub ich.
Da wird dann eine, wird dann entweder NA oder EU oder so ausgeschaltet.
Aber es ist schon hart, ne.
Hier war mal komplett Ausfall.
Aber allein schon, dass der Peak zu dem peakt, das ist...
Und ja, natürlich ist normal, dass MMOs Spieler verlieren.
Aber das Spiel ist eineinhalb Monate raus.
Da sind die Leute normalerweise noch voll im Erkundungsdrang bei MMOs und alles.
Das ist ja nix.
Also das hat eindeutig andere Probleme.
So, aber, jetzt muss ich mal gucken, wo ich das Video hin hab.
Hier liegt, liegt Footage.
Ich glaub, ich hab das extra, weil ich mir gedacht hab, dass das einer von euch gucken will.
Oder einer.
Der eine Chat, das gucken will, hab ich das, glaub ich, hier hin.
Und das Video wollte ich nicht wirklich veröffentlichen unter diesem Titel.
Aber, mir ist kein anderer an der Teilnahme eingefallen.
Ähm, gucken wir mal.
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz checken, ob das auch das richtige Video ist.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwas leake.
Zack.
Zerstörung? Warum Zerstörung?
Ach, ach, ach so.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und mich hat heute...
Okay, das ist das richtige Video.
Jaja, das ist das richtige Video.
Excellent.
Was ist denn mit VLC?
Oh, unterstützt durch EA steht da oben auch.
Haha, dieses Video ist...
Dieses Video ist definitiv nicht unterstützt durch EA.
Ich glaub, das ist das letzte Video, was EA unterstützen würde.
Im Leben nicht.
Das muss ich rausnehmen.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich mach's doch im VLC.
Das Video ist nicht unterstützt durch EA.
Das hab ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen da reingerendert.
Ich hab's vergessen.
... auf Twitch im Stream gefragt.
Max, sag mal, was gefällt dir an Battlefield 20?
Hallo, Max, sehr gut.
... besser als an allen anderen Battlefields.
Da musste ich nachdenken und mir ist echt nichts gescheites eingefallen.
Das hat mich bisschen umgetrieben.
Deswegen setz ich mich jetzt auch hier hin.
Das hat mich inspiriert, dass ich mir dachte,
hey, ich muss jetzt einfach mal Klartext über das Game reden.
Und ich sag gleich, ich hab echt kein Problem,
wer das Game geil findet, wer das Game...
Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
... abfeiert. Ich find's gut. Sollt ihr machen.
Und ich sag euch, wie's ist.
Ich bin Battlefield-Fanboy durch und durch.
Allerdings auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad.
Denn ich erkenne noch...
Dann machen wir's gerade so.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Und mich hat heute jemand auf Twitch im Stream gefragt.
Max, sag mal,
was gefällt dir an Battlefield 2042 besser
als an allen anderen Battlefields?
So ist gut, so ist gut, ne?
Da musste ich nachdenken und mir ist echt nichts gescheites eingefallen.
Das hat mich bisschen umgetrieben.
Dann halt ich jetzt mal die Klappe
und lass...
mich für mich selbst sprechen.
... mich jetzt auch hierhin.
Das hat mich zu diesem Video inspiriert,
dass ich mir dachte, hey, ich muss jetzt einfach mal Klartext über das Game reden.
Und ich sag gleich, ich hab echt kein Problem,
wer das Game geil findet, wer das Game abfeiert.
Ich find's gut. Sollt ihr machen.
Schön, dass ihr euren Spaß dran habt.
Und ich sag euch, wie's ist.
Ich bin Battlefield-Fanboy durch und durch.
Was ja auch wirklich so ist.
... auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad.
Denn ich erkenne noch Kacke, wenn sie einem vorgesetzt wird.
Und Battlefield 2042
hat leider relativ viel Kacke.
Und ich wäre, und ihr wisst's, Leute,
die mich schon länger verfolgen willst,
ich wäre der glücklichste Spieler der Welt gewesen,
wenn Battlefield 2042 einfach
Ich hab keine Probleme. Mittlerweile bin ich das gewöhnt,
meine eigene Stimme zu hören.
... nur geil gewesen wäre.
Aber heute müssen wir uns mal drum kümmern,
warum es nicht so geil ist, wie es hätte theoretisch sein.
Zack, ich muss mal kurz die Emotes kleiner machen.
... können.
Und ich werde auch gar nicht auf den 1000 oder was weiß ich.
Ich sag mal 50.000, gibt ja so viele Bugs.
Da wäre ich gar nicht so sehr drauf rumreiten,
weil das Game hat viele grundlegende Probleme.
Also sagen wir mal Kernprobleme,
die gar nicht so sehr mit den Bugs zu tun haben.
Die Bugs kann man alle fixen,
aber viele Kerndesignentscheidungen
sind einfach sehr fragwürdig.
Und ich frag mich aber trotzdem bei diesem Release,
hatte Battlefield 2042 wirklich
irgendeine Art von Testing
oder QA
intern oder QS, also Qualitätssicherung?
Ich kann mir das kaum vorstellen.
Das Game hat kaum Inhalt
und ist broken as fuck.
Ich weiß, es gibt genug Leute, die sagen
Battlefield 2042,
das ist die größte Battlefield-Packung aller Zeiten.
Da denke ich mir, was?
Seid ihr noch bei Trost?
Das Game hat eigentlich überhaupt keinen Inhalt,
außer Hovercraft, davon hat es viele.
Also das sehe ich komplett anders.
Aber erstmal ein bisschen abregen.
Kommen wir gleich zu übrigens der Day 1 Patch,
der morgen früh um 8 Uhr oder so erscheint.
Der wird da wahrscheinlich
auch nicht großartig das ändern.
Können sie ja auch gar nicht.
Dazu gibt es ein Update.
Es gab nämlich schon
einen Teil des Day 1 Patches heute.
Und
der hat eigentlich
so gut wie nichts gefixt.
Der große Teil kommt aber morgen.
Der hat so gut wie nichts gefixt,
hat aber wieder andere Sachen kaputt gemacht.
Zum Beispiel hast du jetzt viel öfters
bei deinen eigenen Teammates gar keinen Namen
und sie sehen aus wie ein Gegner.
Also
vorher kam das ab und zu mal vor.
Jetzt kommt das jede Runde
quasi bei einem Viertel
vom Team vor.
Also der Patch hat
eher noch ein bisschen mehr kaputt gemacht.
Aber ich mach mal weiter.
Der Patch muss erstmal zertifiziert werden für Konsolen.
Und die Sachen, die jetzt auffallen
in dieser Woche, ist sehr fragwürdig,
ob davon überhaupt irgendwas in diesem Patch
gelandet ist. Obwohl der Patch wahrscheinlich
unglaublich groß sein wird.
Es geht zum größten Teil hier in diesem Video um Design.
Und den Kern des Games
geht nicht so sehr um die Bugs.
Und ich hab mir so eine Liste, grob eine Liste gemacht
mit Punkten, über die ich einfach mal reden will.
Wenn es euch gefällt, dann könnt ihr mir an der Stelle
jetzt ein Abo dalassen. Würde mich sehr freuen.
Und mir ist jetzt aufgefallen auch
übrigens, warum das Game so viele Mitarbeiter hatte.
Nachdem ich mir die Maps mal eine Weile...
Ja, angeblich hat der Patch 60 Gigabyte.
Das heißt, der Patch ist größer
als das Game. Mal gucken, ob sich diese
Leaks bewahrheiten.
...angeguckt habe, ist mir das sofort klar geworden.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum das quasi
das größte Battlefield aller Zeiten ist. Die meisten Mitarbeiter
hatte, die müssten für das Map Design
Hirntote aus umliegenden Krankenhäusern
angeheuert haben. Anders kann ich mir das Ganze
nicht erklären. Oder aber
die Manager von EA haben denen
mit Deadlines so extrem im Nacken
gesessen, dass sie quasi schon
eingedrungen sind.
Nicht, dass da dran was Schlimmes wäre.
Ich hab mir gedacht, da hab ich's jetzt ein bisschen
übertrieben, das kann ich so nicht hochladen.
Also anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären,
wie da teilweise in diese Sachen
in diesem Game gelandet sind.
Aber ohne Spaß, das Game hat
sich jetzt schon sicherlich 5 Jahre meiner Lebenszeit
gekostet. Ich brauch wahrscheinlich bald Blutdruckpillen
oder sonstige, oder Herzmedikamente
oder sonst irgendwie sowas. Aber ich
wollte mich ja wieder ein bisschen abregen. Ich würde sagen,
fangen wir aber gleich mit diesem Thema an.
Maps, Spieleranzahl
und Spielmodi. Mehr ist
nicht immer besser. Es ist ja eigentlich
eine ganz gute Idee. Man könnte
sagen, mehr Spieler, machen wir einfach die Maps
größer. Leider hat man das Ganze nicht
zu Ende gedacht. Bei Conquest
funzt das ja noch halbwegs gut, aber
bei Breakthrough, all
weiter, bei Breakthrough, was haben die sich denn dabei
gedacht? Bei Breakthrough, also wenn
diesen Modus, das heißt glaube ich Durchbruch auf Deutsch,
wer diesen Modus nicht kennt, der wird ja immer mit
Rush verglichen. Aber wenn noch einer, ich raste
aus, ohne Scheiß, ich dreh
am Rad, wenn noch einer sagt, Breakthrough ist
wie Rush. Das einzige, was
in Breakthrough wie Rush ist, ist, dass es
meistens, auch nicht immer, meistens
zwei Bases gibt, die man
einnehmen muss. Aber ansonsten hat das mit Rush, vor allem
in Battlefield 2042, gar nichts
zu tun. Breakthrough hast du
zwei, meistens zwei
Flaggen, die du capturen musst.
Ich hab's ein bisschen übertrieben,
ja, ich geb's dir ja zu.
Ich hab's ein bisschen übertrieben, deswegen lade ich
das auch nicht hoch.
Das Problem ist nur, dass die Maps so krass
offen sind und meistens nur lieblos irgendwo
random Flaggen verteilt werden, dass es
oftmals gar nicht möglich ist,
diese Sachen richtig zu capturen, auch von
der Platzierung her, der Objectives,
dass man sich gedacht hat, okay,
wir sammeln uns jetzt
alle an einer Fahne und da hast du 128
an einer Fahne stehen, es ist wir.
Kommen wir aber gleich beim Thema Maps da noch
ein bisschen genauer zu.
Das eigentliche Problem an Breakthrough ist eigentlich,
dass sich in Gebieten,
wo sich früher quasi
16 vs. 16 gekloppt haben,
weil es gibt ja immer nur noch
1, 2, 3 Flaggen, also Gebiete,
wo früher 16 vs. 16 oder höchstens
32 vs. 32 war,
jetzt 128
Spieler hocken. Das ist Cluster
Fuck hoch 3 und viele Maps
funktionieren in Breakthrough einfach nicht.
Bei Conquest ist das ein bisschen anders.
Dort ist es oftmals 2 Minuten Rennen
bis zum Umfallen und dann Cluster Fuck
oder du hast einen richtig nice
Flank gemacht, was in dem Game auch schon eine Weile dauert
und dann spawnen beim
Capturen der Flagge 40 Leute rein.
Ja, it's GG, get rekt.
Kannst du auch nichts großartiges dagegen machen.
Und es ist einfach nicht durchdacht.
Zum Beispiel gegen diese langen Laufwege
sollte eigentlich,
sollten entweder viele Fahrzeuge auf der Map
sein oder es gibt jetzt ja dieses Airdrop System.
Da kann man B drücken, da kann man
sich einen Ranger holen oder einen Hover
Craft. Ich will jetzt gar nicht davon anfangen.
Oder ein Hovercraft oder sonst was.
Aber mal ernsthaft, das ist
einfach nur aufgesetzter Mist.
Nicht nur, dass das Hovercraft hirnlos
OP ist. Ich glaube, da hat sich glaube ich
jetzt jeder schon darüber ausgelassen. Das muss ich jetzt nicht machen.
Sondern es gibt fast nichts.
Im Airdrop Menü gibt es 3 Kategorien
mit jeweils 1 bis 2 Sachen. Von diesem komischen
Roboterhund, dann Anti-Air
und ein Ranger und ein Hovercraft
und sowas in der Richtung. Aber
man hat eine extra Mechanik
eingeführt, in der fast nichts
drin ist. Das ist so sinnbildlich für
viele Sachen in Battlefield 2042.
Ich will jetzt Pause machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob
wer das Spiel noch nicht hat.
Das ist eines der Punkte,
die ich hätte besser ausführen müssen.
Und zwar
man kann sich ja
zur Fortbewegung so einen Airdrop
rufen in dem Spiel. Aber in diesem
Airdrop Menü gibt es legit nur
5 Sachen.
Also es gibt
Ranger, es gibt ein Hovercraft,
es gibt
ein Auto
zum Fahren.
General Slane, danke für den Sub.
Und es gibt Anti-Air und ein Panzer, glaube ich.
Also es gibt 5 Sachen.
Das ist einfach eine neue Mechanik
für quasi fast nichts.
Magst du es aber am aufregen? Ja.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es finde ich ein bisschen übertrieben
in dem Video.
Aber man hat eine extra Mechanik
eingeführt, in der fast
nichts drin ist. Das ist so sinnbildlich
für viele Sachen in Battlefield 2042.
Das ist von den Ansätzen hat man
sich da eigentlich mal was ganz Gutes
gedacht. Aber es ist einfach nichts da.
Und ob das noch so ausgebaut
wird, dass es wirklich sinnvoll ist, da habe ich meine
großen Zweifel dran. Und ich denke mir, so hat man
keine Ideen mehr gehabt. Wenn man sowas
einbaut und einem nichts einfällt,
was man da einbauen kann, dann
ist das doch meistens ein Hinweis darauf, dass es
eine dumme Idee ist, das Ding überhaupt einzubauen.
Und zur Fortbewegung über die Map
funktioniert das auch nicht richtig, weil das
viel zu selten überhaupt benutzbar ist.
Das heißt, es bleibt in der Regel
nur rennen. Und das ist einfach
das ist einfach dumm.
Also der Sepp, ich weiß nicht wie du das findest,
aber ich finde das Game ist einfach
mitten in der Entwicklung auf den Markt geworfen
worden. Es ist weder
also von den
von wie es gedacht
ist fertig, noch wie es
implementiert ist fertig.
Also es ist weder fertig durchdacht,
noch fertig programmiert.
Die Größe der Maps ist eines der für mich
schlimmsten Entscheidungen
an Battlefield 2042.
Die 128 Spieler, das könnte eigentlich alles
funktionieren, ist aber in Kombination
mit den Maps
ja einfach nur
undurchdacht und man wollte
irgendwas haben, was man groß anpreisen
kann. Und jetzt mal zu den Maps.
Da hätte ich auch ein bisschen
mehr drauf eingehen müssen.
Oder generell hätte ich ein bisschen Flamme
weglassen müssen und besser drauf eingehen.
Ich bin mittlerweile der Ansicht,
dass es 128 Spieler
gibt, ist
einfach nur drinnen, damit man
marketingmäßig was hat, was man verkaufen
kann. Nicht aus
sinnvollen Gameplay Gründen.
Die haben festgestellt, sie kriegen nichts sinnvolles
auf die Reihe, in dieser Zeit, wie auch immer
und sie haben ein paar dicke, große
Marketingdinger gebraucht. Was haben sie
genommen? Ihre Wettereffekte und 128
Spieler. Das wurde ja breit
getreten wie sonst was. Beides
eigentlich nichts, was das
Spiel zum besseren ändert.
Konkret selber.
Meine Güte.
Also wirklich.
Ich habe noch nie, wirklich noch nie,
nirgendwo so schlechte Maps
gesehen für das, was auf ihnen gespielt wird.
Gerade Breakthrough. Ich habe es ja gerade am Anfang
schon ein bisschen, ja so mir
von der Seele geredet, aber du musst ja noch ein bisschen
genauer drauf eingehen. Gerade in Breakthrough.
Die Frage in Battlefield 2042 ist ja
gar nicht mal, welche Maps sind gut,
sondern eigentlich eher, welche Maps
sind nicht so kacke. Gehen wir mal durch.
Hourglass.
Die Wüstenmap.
Absoluter Trash in Breakthrough
wegen den Hochhäusern und vorher auch schon.
Jetzt geht's los, jetzt geht's los, ja.
Und wegen den Hochhäuser
leider auch Trash auf Kongfest.
Discarded. Das ist die Map mit dem kaputten Schiff.
Kompletter Trash, zumindest in der
immer in der ersten Hälfte
auf Breakthrough
und Kongfest glaube ich ganz nice
für Heli-Liebhaber.
Für Infanterie kann man sich drüber streiten,
aber auf dem Schiff ist auch ganz nice. Also Kongfest, okay.
Breakthrough, kompletter Trash.
Manifest. Beste Map im Spiel.
Keine Ahnung, was es mit
Containermaps ist, aber die können sie
Bad Dice irgendwie. Guckt euch Nosha Kellels
an. Containermaps. Containermaps kriegen sie
irgendwie auf die Reihe. Kaleidoskop.
Städtemap. Ist ganz okay
in Breakthrough, aber letzter Punkt
ist komplett lächerlich auf dem Hochhaus oben.
Hat den Scheiß mal irgendwann
jemand getestet? Der letzte Punkt
auf dem Hochhaus ist nicht
einnehmbar. Das klappt nicht. Wie gesagt,
Hourglass hat ähnliche Probleme. Kongfest
geht irgendwie.
So, nächste Map. Orbital.
Erschreckenderweise eine der
ganz guten Maps. Tja,
ich hab's in der Beta schon gesagt, wenn das
eines der besten Maps ist, dann gute Nacht. Aber
tatsächlich, Orbital ist eines der besten
Maps. Leider in Breakthrough
dank dem Hochhaus
auch gar nicht
richtig spielbar. Aber in Orbital
sieht man, dass es was
bringt, das zu testen. Die Map ist nach
der Beta noch verbessert worden.
Beispielsweise mit ein bisschen mehr Schutt auf dem Flug,
wenn man auf dem Flugfeld. Und als nächstes
Breakaway.
Mehr muss ich dazu nicht sagen. Dann haben wir noch
Renewal. Und Renewal
ist diese Map zwischen Grün
und Wüste. Da muss ich sagen,
C1, ich glaube C1 ist das,
das im Haus in der Mitte zwischen Grün und Wüste,
da sind nice Fights drum herum
möglich. Breakthrough ist die Map
wirklich ganz gut. Ich finde das eigentlich mit
die beste Breakthrough Map. Allerdings
auch in Kongfest ist die ganz gut.
Aber leider
wie alle Maps oder wie die meisten
Maps viel, viel, viel zu offen
und viel, viel, viel zu viel random Fahrzeuge
am Start. Du hast die Fahrzeuge in der Base
spawnen. Du hast dann gefühlt irgendwie jeder
fährt mit 5 Hovercrafts rum. Das ist
einfach
das, was Battlefield
irgendwie für mich auch ausgezeichnet
hat, ist die gute Balance zwischen
Infantry, Action, Fahrzeug Gameplay.
Du hast eher Map Objectives.
Und das fällt komplett auseinander
auf diesen Maps. Und oft
ist es auch so, dadurch, dass die Maps eben so oft
offen sind, wer eher dominiert,
also wer die besseren Heli-Piloten hat,
der fickt, und anders kann ich sagen,
der Gachibas, der fickt
die Gegner so krass weg.
Es gibt ja kaum Deckung. Da gewinnst du mit
700 zu 0 Tickets. Easy.
Also ich glaube Heli-Piloten
haben auf den meisten Maps wirklich Spaß, wenn sie
gut sind. Allerdings muss man auch sagen,
ich bin ja ein paar mal mit dem Eax zusammen
Gunner geflogen. Also die
Heli-Physik ist auch so eine Frage für sich. Ja, wenn man
den Heli auf den Kopf stellt, fliegt der nicht richtig runter und sowas.
Aber ich glaube Heli-Piloten haben dann auch
potenziell den meisten Spaß dran.
Alternativ natürlich
haben wir hier Heli-Piloten?
Also
ist das, ist da mal eine Einschätzung? Kommt
das hin? Mögt ihr das Game?
Fährt man mit
dem Hovercraft 20 Minuten im Kreis und macht
150 Kills. Okay, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben.
50 Kills. Also alle Maps
sind flach und wirken für mich
wie aus irgend so einem Terroir
Gebiet, Random Generator.
Hat man sich generieren lassen, einfach eine Map,
hat man drei Häuser drauf geklatscht,
paar Kisten drauf gesetzt,
paar Zäune drauf gemacht,
fertig ist die Battlefield 2042 Map.
Guckt euch mal Kaleidoskop an.
Übrigens eine noch der etwas besseren
designten Maps, ja. Allerdings
selbst da sind Teile schlicht und ergreifend komplett
unfertig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diesen Bunker kennt. Ich glaube
E1 ist das. Das ist einfach nur
ein
Bunker. Das ist nicht mal ein Bunker, das ist
irgendwie ein Loch in der Map mit
einem Loch im Dach und
das hat einfach komplett, da ist nichts drin.
Absolut gar nichts. Das ist einfach
nur weiß.
Hier müsste ich ein Bild zu machen.
Ich glaube das finde ich nicht.
Sonst hätte ich euch jetzt mal ein Bild dazu
gezeigt. Ich guck mal nebenbei, ob ich ein Bild dazu finde.
Das könnte fast schon die Test
Textur sein. Das ist einfach nur weiß
und das Licht klitscht durch die Wand.
Das ist einfach nicht fertig.
Der hätte noch eine halbe,
die Mapper hätten noch ein halbes Jahr an der Map
rumbauen müssen. Weiße Wand Textur
und nichts, einfach nichts drin.
Keine Liebe zum Detail. Komplett unfertig.
Und das
ist in Kombination mit 128
Spielern einfach nur wild.
Anders kann man das nicht ausdrücken.
Und für einen Gegner, den du
siehst, sehen dich meistens fünf
andere. Das ist so offen
und dass Landschaftsmaps
prinzipiell funktionieren, ich nenne das jetzt mal Landschaftsmaps,
aber dass Landschaftsmaps
prinzipiell funktionieren hat man Bad Company 2 gesehen.
Bad Company 2 ist für mich so der Inbegriff von
Landschaftsmaps. Guckt euch Valparaiso
an, guckt euch Port Valdes an. Das sind
alles meistens auch
Eureka Harbour. Das sind meistens auch
Landschaftsmaps, die ein Thema haben.
Schnee, Wüste, Dschungel, Gras,
wie auch immer. Die sind auch relativ offen
und Bad Company 2 konntest du auch noch relativ viel
zerstören. Am Ende einer Runde sahen
Bad Company 2 Maps fast den Boden
eingeäschert aus oftmals. Aber
da hatte man eben keine 128
Spieler und
die Maps waren wirklich gut für den Spielmodus
designt. Also man hat sich da sehr viel Gedanken
gemacht. Ich entdecke heute noch in
Battlefield 3, beispielsweise letztens erst
auf Grand Bazaar,
auf Sand Crossing,
Dinger, wo ich mir denke, fuck, da haben die sich ja was richtig
Gutes dabei gedacht. Da ist genau dort
Line of Sight, Blocker, ne Kiste,
dass die Gegner rüber können und sowas. Wo ich denke,
fuck man, das fällt dir nach 10
Jahren mit dem Game auf. Richtig
Big-Brain-Ideen hatten
die bei DICE. Aber das erkenne ich jetzt
bei Battlefield 2042 Maps
wirklich
nicht.
Wo machen wir an der Stelle weiter?
Klar, manche Maps in Battlefield in den alten
Jahren waren auch nicht so gut wie andere.
Aber immer noch meilenweit besser als
Battlefield 2042.
Dazu kommt, es gibt keine Map Selection.
Du kannst nicht etwa auswählen,
ich möchte jetzt die und die Maps spielen und diese
auf gar keinen Fall. Das heißt, ihr müsst
auch die dreckigsten der dreckigen Maps,
ihr müsst die spielen. Außer man
quittet und joint 10 mal wieder neu rein.
Ich meine, wer ist
auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen? Warum DICE?
Warum kann ich nicht die Maps spielen,
die ich will? Dazu kommt, dass es
ich weiß nicht, wie man das korrekt
dabei sind, so Force Spawn gibt am Anfang.
Du bist gezwungen zu spawnen.
Und du bist gezwungen, dir sinnlose Cutscenes
anzugucken. Am Anfang von
jeder Map kommt am Anfang
irgendwie Grinch-Sprüche von deinen
Specialists. Dann musst du
dir angucken, wie du mit dem Heli reinfliegst.
Dann musst du dir irgendwelches Radio-Geschwätz
angucken. Dann musst du irgendwie ein komisches
Intro-Video angucken. Und dann wirst du auch noch
ob du willst oder nicht gespawnt.
Das ist einfach nur... Das wurde gefixt
mit dem Patch heute.
Ich hab vorhin...
Ich hab vorhin zwei Runden gespielt.
Das wurde gefixt mit dem Patch heute.
Du kannst
jetzt... Zumindest
ging das vorhin bei mir.
Wenn du im Menü rumklickst, zu dem Zeitpunkt
wo du Force gespawnt
wirst,
bleibst du im Spawn-Bildschirm drin.
Es könnte natürlich sein, dass das selbst
wiederum ein Bug ist. Dass das nicht sein soll.
Das Spiel
sollte... Ein Chat sagt gerade, das Spiel sollte
ein Battle Royale werden, weil EA es wollte.
EA wollte an Warzone konkurrieren. Ja, da gibt's ein guter
Gerücht. Das Gerücht gibt's ja schon eine Weile.
Und das
passt auch. Also, das deckt sich auch
mit den Maps und auch mit diesen
Specialist-Ideen. Ich glaube,
sie wollten...
Also, Warzone
war der urspr... Äh, nicht Warzone. Ähm...
Hazard Zone war der ursprüngliche Modus.
Ich glaube, sie wollten so eine
Escape from Tarkov
Hunt Showdown Battle Royale
Mischmasch-Geschichte machen. Und haben dann
festgestellt, hm...
Vielleicht verkauft sich das in der Form, wie wir das jetzt
machen, doch nicht so gut. Oder haben
festgestellt, Hazard Zone allein
trägt wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wir machen daraus doch noch ein Battlefield.
Einfach für Money.
Und in dem Zustand sind wir jetzt.
Wir sind quasi halb fertig mit der
Entwicklung bei diesem Game und haben's jetzt schon rausgeprügelt.
Soll ich mal weiter?
Bescheid. Und warum ist das Ganze so? Na klar.
Damit man die Specialist sieht und die Leute
Bock auf Skins und Voice Packs oder sonst was
bekommen. Anderen Sinn hat das nicht.
Am Ende kommt das auch noch.
Bis zu einem gewissen Teil. Das ist so
nervig. Ich will in ein Game reinjoinen
und es soll losgehen.
Chat, es gibt keinen Server
in Battlefield 2042.
Es gibt Portal,
damit kannst du zwar eigene Spielmodi
hosten, aber sobald du raus
gehst und die Spieler rausgehen,
geht der Server wieder zu. Es gibt
keine persistenten Server. Das ist komplett
unsinnig, gerade so wie das ist.
Es ist Serverless
sozusagen, genau.
Nur nicht das, was
man sich eigentlich unter Serverless vorstellt.
Aber es ist Serverless.
Und losgehen, wie gesagt, heißt in Battlefield 2042
vor Spawn.
In der Beta ging das übrigens noch.
In der Beta konntest du einfach warten.
Die Runde ging los. Du hast gewartet, bis vielleicht
ein Heli in guter Position war.
Also warten auf einen guten Einstieg und Spawnpunkt.
Nein, das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Du wirst aus dem Menü geworfen. Du musst spawnen.
Ob du willst oder nicht. Obwohl
es nicht mal im Spawn genug Fahrzeuge
gibt, um ohne 3 Minuten Rennen zu
der nächsten Flagge zu kommen.
Das ist einfach so bescheuert.
Und man sieht es total oft.
Guckt euch mal um bei dem Start der Runde. Es werden
einfach instant 20 Leute um euch drum herum sterben.
Die redeployen einfach, bohren
ein bisschen in der Nase und warten, bis es einen guten
Spawnpunkt gibt.
Was ein mega dummes
System. Ja. Nächster Punkt.
Das Spiel, und das habe ich
am Anfang schon angesprochen, da werden wir wahrscheinlich viele nicht
zugestimmt haben. Das Spiel hat keinen
Inhalt in den Kerndistri...
Ja, das Video vom Lost war gut. Das habe ich auch geguckt.
Gibt ja, wie gesagt,
genug, die sagen, ah, die größte Battlefield-Packung
aller Zeiten. Ja, wo ist die denn?
Portal ist keiner aus. Ja, ich mache das, wie gesagt,
das lade ich nicht hoch. Äh,
Viktor, ich mache, äh,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
morgen oder so ein Video
dazu. Aber das ist ja noch, das ist ja noch nicht fertig.
Ich rage jetzt ja noch 10 Minuten hier rum.
Da kommt noch mehr.
Oder? Ja, wir sind
jetzt die Hälfte fertig, Mann. Ich habe noch
einige Sachen, worüber ich mich aufregen kann.
Portal ist ein netter
Zusatz, den man eingebaut hat, damit man
die massig Leute, die man zum Entwickeln hatte, irgendwie
schön parallelisieren konnte. Portal ist
keine Ausrede. Erstens, Battlefield
Bad Company 2, Battlefield 3... Leute, Leute,
zuhören! Das ist, finde ich, wichtig.
Zusatz, den man eingebaut hat...
Gibt ja, wie gesagt, genug, die sagen, ah,
die pläuen einfach.
Oh, ein bisschen in der Nase und... Da werden wir wahrscheinlich
viele nicht zugestimmt haben. So, jetzt, jetzt. Das Spiel hat
keinen Inhalt in den
Kerndisziplinen. Gibt ja, wie gesagt,
genug, die sagen, ah, die größte Battlefield-Packung
aller Zeiten. Ja, wo ist die denn?
Portal ist keine Ausrede.
Portal ist ein netter Zusatz, den man
eingebaut hat, damit man die massig Leute,
die man zum Entwickeln hatte, irgendwie schön parallelisieren
konnte. Portal ist keine Ausrede.
Erstens, Battlefield Bad Company 2,
Battlefield 3 sind Ausgeburten
der Hölle in Portal. Hat mit dem Original
nichts zu tun. Da fehlt so ziemlich alles,
was das Original ausgemacht hat. Da kann ich
aber auch BidoBand das Original spielen. Also, Battlefield 3
ist einfach mal ein Vielfaches besser, als es
Battlefield 3 in Portal
zumal... Nicht nur,
dass es quasi vom Gameplay her verkackt ist,
nein, es ist auch noch kaum Inhalt.
Bad Company 2 hat mit Bad Company 2
eh schon mal überhaupt nichts zu tun. Und
Server gibt es ja auch nicht so wirklich in Portal.
Die Server gehen ja zu, wenn keiner
drauf ist. Oder nach einer gewissen Zeit.
Ich glaube, wenn genug drauf waren, dauert es kurz, bis sie wieder
zugehen. Und, dass es direkt am
Anfang XP-Booster-Server geben
wird. Das war so klar.
Leute, als wir jetzt die Portal-Ankündigung
im Stream auf YouTube angeguckt
haben,
also im Twitch-Stream das YouTube-Video
geguckt haben, das erste,
legit, ich müsste das mal raussuchen,
eines der ersten Sachen, die ich gesagt habe, ist
Leute, wie sieht das aus? Kann man
da nicht Booster-Server machen? Oh, das ist jetzt passiert!
Das erste, was passiert ist, Booster-Server!
Könnt ihr keine
5 Meter mehr weit denken? Wenn mir das
beim Zugucken das erste, was mir in den Kopf kommt, ist
Booster-Server? Ja, Booster-Server!
Das war so klar, dass es
Booster-Server geben wird.
Oh Mann. Wie gesagt, das einzig wirklich
große in diesem Spiel sind die Maps. Und mal
ehrlich, es sind auch nur 7 Maps.
Die können, die können
zwar groß sein, aber
es gibt ganze
2, ich wiederhole,
2 Spielmodi.
Also in der Kerndisziplin
All Out Warfare, Conquest und
Breakthrough. Und Breakthrough ist auf Hälfte der Maps
nicht richtig spielbar.
Das war's. Das ist alles.
Wenn man nett ist, rechnet man noch Hazard Zone
dazu. Aber das war's. Das ist
der Inhalt. Ja, du hast jetzt noch die Specialist
dabei, über die will ich übrigens gar nicht
so viel flamen. Finde ich immer noch
eigentlich vom Ansatz her gar nicht so schlecht.
Ähm, das war's.
Wo sind die ganzen Spielmodi hin?
Ja? Wo sind richtig gute
Maps? 7 Maps, 2 Spielmodi.
Und du kannst doch nicht mal irgendwie was
auswählen. Und nein, Portal ist eben
keine Ausrede dafür. Das war's.
Masse statt Klasse, könnte man sagen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass
Battlefield 2042 in dem was es bietet
meistens zum größten Teil
nicht mal Klasse hat. Und auch
nicht mal Masse. Ja, was soll denn da am Ende
bei rauskommen? Und
auch ein beliebtes
Argument. Ja, ich weiß, fast jeder
Battlefield Launch war irgendwie
kaputt, verbuggt.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich muss sagen,
also sowohl Battlefield
5 als auch 1
hatte ich jetzt nicht so, aber habe ich auch nicht viel gespielt.
Gar nicht so schlimm in Erinnerung. Ja, aber
vielleicht erinnert es euch jemand an Battlefield 4.
Das war so mega kaputt.
Ja, ich kann mich noch an einen Moment
erinnern in Battlefield 4 nach Release. Da bist du
gerade ausgelaufen, auf einmal hast du Instant beschleunigt,
bist gegen Betonblock geschlagen
und warst tot. Und ich so, hä? Moment, Leute,
ich muss es kurz, ich muss euch das Video
kurz zeigen.
Ich muss euch das Video kurz zeigen.
Das ist einfach, einfach das
Beste aus der Battlefield 4 Beta.
Nein.
Ah, das hier.
Elf Sekunden, das müsst ihr euch
eigentlich, das ist, das ist, das ist top.
Wobei ich glaube, das ist sogar schon released.
Ich lach mich da, kann mich da immer noch
kaputt lachen, wenn ich das sehe.
Dumdi dumdi dum.
Einfach laufen, vorwärts laufen,
auf einmal bam.
Was ist denn mit Carsten los?
Genau.
Ich kann mir das,
ich lach mich da immer noch,
das ist so dumm.
Einfach nix, nix los.
Beklatscht er einfach gegen die Wand.
Okay, ich fahr weiter.
Ist gut, ist gut.
So, ja, auf geht's.
Mega kaputt.
Ich kann mich noch an einen Moment erinnern,
in Battlefield 4 nach Release.
Da bist du grad ausgelaufen, auf einmal hast du
Instant beschleunigt, bist gegen Betonblock geschlagen
und warst tot.
Was ist denn hier los?
Aber, der große Unterschied ist,
warum man sich das diesmal nicht damit schönreden kann.
Also erstens ist das eh schon kein Argument zu sagen,
es ist immer kacke, deswegen muss es,
es war immer kacke, deswegen muss es diesmal auch kacke sein.
Aber selbst, wenn man sich das schönreden will,
ein Vorteil hatte Battlefield 4.
Und der war auch schon zur verpacktesten Zeit
von Battlefield 4 zu erkennen.
Battlefield 4 hatte einen goldenen Kern.
Den hat man erkannt.
Er war nicht so wirklich gut benutzbar,
weil das Spiel verpackt als Fuck war, als es rausgekommen ist.
Aber es hatte eindeutig einen goldenen Kern.
Es hat lange gedauert, das so weit zu polieren,
dass der quasi nach außen schien.
Battlefield 2042.
Naja.
Das Spiel hat seine Momente.
Ich würd mal sagen,
das hat vielleicht ein paar Silberstücke
in einem sehr hohen,
sehr großen Haufen Trash.
Ja, Müll.
Deswegen bin ich da nicht so zuversichtlich,
was Battlefield 2042 angeht.
Es sind einfach viel zu viele grundlegende,
im Kern vorhandene Designentscheidungen,
denen ich nicht zustimme und sage,
das ist in weiten Teilen
nur der Schatten eines Battlefield-Games.
Versteht mich nicht falsch,
wie gesagt, das Game hat seine Momente,
aber die sind meistens dort,
wo eben nichts
verschlimmbessert wurde.
Zum Beispiel Manifest-Containern.
Haben wir gestern gesehen, Leute,
die besten Sachen im Stream waren da,
wo es überschaubare
Close-Quarter-Action-Infanterie
basiert gab.
Das hat richtig Spaß gemacht.
Sei es in dem kaputten Schiff,
sei es in Häusern,
an den Containern.
Dort, wo es überschaubare
Battlefield-Style-Infanterie-Action gab.
Die Katze gibt es noch.
Die auf dem Bild gibt es noch.
Aber
die zweite gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Aber Chico gibt es noch.
Oder in den Häusern oben.
Close-Quarters. Überschaubare Anzahl an Leuten.
Oftmals zumindest.
Klassische Battlefield-Infanterie-Action.
Das macht Bock.
Das spielt sich dann auch wie Battlefield.
Das fühlt sich auch wie Battlefield an.
Von Balancing-Sachen mit den Waffen
fange ich hier gar nicht an.
Das kann man alles patchen.
Der nächste Punkt, der mich auch wirklich nervt,
wo ich auch nicht denke, dass sich da irgendwas dran ändern wird,
ist das Bevormundung
beziehungsweise Weichspülen.
Bevormundung der Spieler.
Es gibt keinen Server-Browser,
sodass ich spielen kann, was ich will.
By the way, ich habe es vor über einem Jahr in einem Video gesagt,
dass das so kommen könnte.
Und das war da zwar
nicht hundertprozentig ernst gemeint,
aber schon mit einem
Kern drin, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
das könnte durchaus so kommen.
Und es kam im Endeffekt auch so.
Und alle haben gesagt, Max, das kann nicht sein.
Vielleicht steht uns jetzt ja sogar
Skill-Based-Matchmaking ins Haus.
Als Beweis, dass ich mir das nicht ausdenke,
ich habe genau zu diesem Thema
ein Video gemacht.
Am 23. März,
also, okay, nicht ganz ein Jahr,
aber noch bevor man wusste,
dass Battlefield 2042 wird,
zu genau diesem Thema, wo ich gesagt habe,
sie können das eigentlich nur machen,
indem sie den Server-Browser ausbauen.
Also die Hälfte des Videos geht um,
dass Battlefield keinen Server-Browser mehr haben wird.
Und in dem Video unten drunter haben sie alle gesagt,
ja, Max, das kann nicht sein.
Du erzählst,
du erzählst Blödsinn
und sowas.
Die meisten haben mir durchaus zugestimmt.
Aber ich hatte Recht.
Predicted.
Alle Voraussetzungen dafür sind da.
Ich hoffe ja nicht, dass es so weit kommt.
Okay, es gibt kein Scoreboard.
Da haben sich alle jetzt schon drüber ausgelassen,
ich mich auch.
Kein Chat, wo ich bei, wie gesagt,
ich habe das im letzten Video vielleicht ein bisschen falsch ausgedrückt.
Es gibt einen Chat.
Es gibt einen Chat für Party und Squad und Team.
Aber es gibt keinen Chat für alle.
Also übergreifend.
Über die gesamte Lobby.
Also man kann dem Gegner nichts schreiben.
Egal, ob es was Positives oder was Negatives ist.
Man kann auch seinen Squad
nicht mehr gescheit wechseln.
Es wird einfach random
einem ein Squad zugewiesen.
Man kann in das Scoreboard gehen
und wenn man das dann in diesem verkackten UI verstanden hat,
wie man das Squad wechselt,
dann kann man das Squad wechseln.
Dann kann man sagen,
hey, ich möchte jetzt zu diesem Spieler.
Nein, das geht nicht.
Du musst random kommst in irgendein anderes Squad.
What the fuck, Dice, warum?
Ja, dazu kommt, es gibt kein richtiges Scoresystem.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere,
denken wir mal an Battlefield 4.
Du hast coole Aktionen gemacht,
nach cooler Aktion bist dann gestorben
und noch im Death-Bildschirm,
also noch im Respawn-Bildschirm,
sind dann deine Punkte hochgesteckt.
So nach dem Motto C4 Kill, Multikill,
ein richtiges Scoresystem,
kein stackendes Scoresystem.
Das war für viele Leute so ein richtiges Minigame im Battlefield.
Es gab Leute, die haben Battlefield gespielt,
die standen oben im Scoreboard,
hatten 1 zu 20
und hatten aber
80 Defi-Revives
oder sowas.
Das hat denen Spaß gemacht.
Das hat die erfüllt.
Wird es jetzt in dieser Art und Weise nicht mehr geben.
Und das alles nur,
um vordergründig Spieler
vor
Toxic Graben zu schützen.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Das ist ein PvP-Multiplayer-Shooter.
Das ist kein super krasses
Competitive-Game oder so.
Das ist Battlefield.
Das ist ein Casual PvP-Multiplayer-Shooter.
Das ist aber auch kein Bälle-Paradies.
Und mal ernsthaft,
wer schon jemals Overwatch Ranked gespielt hat,
oder das ist ja in anderen
Highly Competitive Games
nicht anders.
Rainbow Six, CS, LOL,
was auch immer, ist egal.
Der kennt das Geflame dort.
Dagegen ist der Battlefield-Chat doch
absoluter Kindergeburtstag.
Und viele Leute in Battlefield,
zumindest meiner Erfahrung nach,
sind sogar recht nett.
Ich habe gestern beispielsweise mega abgeflamed
im Chat über das Game.
Da konnte ich im Video nicht so ausführen.
Ich kann jetzt mehr dazu.
Ich habe mich übelst aufgeregt
im Ingame-Chat.
Nicht nur ich,
da haben viele Leute übelst rumgeflamed.
Und da hat dann wieder einer
so diese Standardsache geschrieben,
so nach dem Motto,
ja, wenn es dir nicht gefällt,
dann kauf es dir nicht.
Und da habe ich ihn übelst beleidigt,
so als was für ein
Kack-Fanboy wieder am Start ist.
Vor allem habe ich es mir doch schon gekauft,
was soll denn das jetzt?
Ich habe mich übelst darüber aufgeregt
und dann hat der, ohne Mist,
dann hat er darauf geantwortet,
so sinngemäß,
aber dann musst du dich nicht so aufregen.
Der hat da ganz normal
und nett darauf geantwortet.
Normalerweise, da sieht man nämlich,
dass in Battlefield gar nicht so viel
krasse Toxic-Scheiße unterwegs ist.
In einem anderen Spiel
hätte sich das so weit hochgeschaukelt,
bis einer von beiden geraged quittet hätte.
Das wird in CS,
in Overwatch auch nicht.
In Overwatch wird dann erstmal
die Mutter beleidigt noch oder so.
Ja, und das war wirklich,
habe ich mir gedacht, siehste,
das stimmt überhaupt nicht,
was sie sagen.
Viele, gerade auch in Battlefield,
jetzt im Speziellen,
sind wirklich nett.
Ja, wie gesagt,
in Overwatch haben die Leute auch teilweise
schon angefangen mit,
wenn du vielleicht nicht
den Held gepickt hast,
den ihnen jetzt vorgeschwebt ist,
oder sie nicht das spielen konnten,
was sie wollten,
dann ging es schon gleich los,
so nach dem Motto hier,
was soll ich machen?
Noob uninstall.
Da ging noch viel mehr los.
Da ging noch viel mehr ab,
wenn die Runde losging.
Und da waren Leute,
die haben tatsächlich nicht mitge...
Die haben da nett drauf geantwortet.
Da gab es noch die Leute,
also am schlimmsten waren die Toxic-Leute,
die AFK gegangen sind.
So nach dem Motto,
die waren mit irgendwas nicht einverstanden,
und anstatt zu flamen,
haben sie mit einem Typ AFK im Spawn
spielen müssen.
Meine Erfahrungen nach
sind sogar recht nett.
Ich habe gestern beispielsweise mega abgeflamt
im Chat über das Game,
und da waren Leute,
die haben tatsächlich nicht mitge...
Die haben da nett drauf geantwortet.
In welchem PvP-Spiel gibt es denn sowas?
Was ist denn hier los?
Und ich habe vorhin
das Video vom Lost geguckt,
und das hat er in seinem Video,
und das sind Leute,
die selber trashtalken,
und dann mit 5 zu 25 im Scoreboard stehen.
Ja, wenn du dann trashtalkt wirst,
dann hast du Pech gehabt.
Da bist du selber dran schuld.
Und warum das alles?
Tja, im Prinzip alles nur,
um Tante Brunhilde
länger bei der Stange zu halten,
damit sie sich auch ja nicht
an irgendwas kleinem gestört fühlen könnte,
dass sie den nächsten Season Pass
oder Voice Pack oder was auch immer kauft.
Wie mit dem Entfernen
der Dislikes auf YouTube.
Man schiebt irgendwas vor,
ja, das machen wir zum Beschützen der Spieler,
ist aber unterm Strich eine echt beschissene Entscheidung.
Und übrigens,
das Gendern in der deutschen Version juckt mich persönlich.
Da hätte ich nichts zu sagen sollen.
Da flippen die Leute drauf aus,
ich sag's euch jetzt schon.
Bei diesem Thema wird eh von allen Seiten
so viel heiße Luft produziert,
dass es nicht mehr feierlich ist.
Am Ende gibt es eh kaum was Unbedeutenderes,
da spielt die englische Version.
Und wen das stört, kann die englische Version spielen.
Ansonsten ist dieses Thema,
egal von welcher Seite betrachtet,
die Luft, die man da zu atmen muss,
um darüber zu diskutieren, gar nicht wert.
Und weder im positiven noch im negativen Sinn.
Und es wirkt generell
in Battlefield 2042,
das wirkt alles so weich gespielt,
wie ich vorhin gesagt hab,
es wirkt wie so ein Schatten eines Battlefields.
Das ist, kann man sich so vorstellen,
wie wenn Battlefield so ein Theaterstück wäre,
ja?
Es würde ein richtig gutes Battlefield laufen,
aber du siehst das Ganze nur so
über einen Schatten an der Wand.
So ungefähr fühlt sich
Battlefield 2042 für mich an,
als jemand, der schon lange Battlefield spielt.
Und es wirkt
einfach weich gespült.
Und dazu kommt, dass man ja auch nicht mit den gleichen Leuten
weiterspielen kann.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich mal unter Bevormundung packen würde.
Nach jeder Runde wird man neu
mit random Leuten zusammengewürfelt.
Wiedererkennungswert gleich 0.
In Battlefield 3, 4 und den anderen auch,
da kannte man die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Zumindest, wenn man auf den gleichen Servern gespielt hat.
Das gibt's ja auch nicht mehr.
Und das ist so, wie es jetzt ist.
Einfach ein total weich gespültes,
anonymisiertes Battlefield,
ohne großartigen Tiefgang.
Geht ja beim Teamplay weiter.
Und ich hacke jetzt, wie gesagt,
nicht so sehr auf Specialists rum,
weil ich die vom Ansatz her immer noch gar nicht so schlecht finde.
Ich weiß, Specialists kriegen viel Hass ab.
Aber ich bin niemand,
der sagt, Specialists sind grundsätzlich
eine scheiß Idee. Aber in allen
alten Battlefield-Teilen war es so,
jeder war irgendwie
auf den anderen angewiesen.
Hey, ich weiß, das Teamplay da auch...
Das finde ich ist jetzt ein echt wichtiger Punkt.
Und Svenno, das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Inwiefern?
Es war im Kern zumindest drin,
dass du als Medic Ammo brauchtest.
Jeder brauchte Spotting, Support brauchte Heals,
jeder brauchte jemanden mit einem Defi,
der einen wieder...
Also jeder konnte irgendwie was geben
und jeder war irgendwie auf das,
was wir hatten, angewiesen.
Nicht so in Battlefield 2042.
Du kannst in diesem Spiel ernsthaft einen Sniper
mit One-Hit-Sniper spielen,
Self-Heal und Ammo-Box
und Motion-Sensor.
Das ist eine komplett self-sustained
Klasse, die sich für 30 Minuten
an den Rand der Map legen kann,
richtig geile Long-Range-Sniper
machen kann, super Montage zusammenschneiden
am Ende auf YouTube und du brauchst nichts.
Du brauchst nichts von deiner Umwelt.
Gar nichts. Und das machen ja auch viele.
Das ist so ein krasser Abfuck.
Zum Glück ist die Hittrack so schlecht,
dass die meistens nicht treffen oder durchschießen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Was hat man sich denn dabei gedacht,
das so zu machen?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Es gibt noch mehr OP-Kombinationen.
Ja, von XP-Boost mit Motion-Sensor,
der jetzt deaktiviert wurde,
deswegen will ich ja gar nicht reden.
Angeblich wurde er deaktiviert,
weil die Maps geleckt haben.
Das kommt bestimmt auch noch dabei.
Aber wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich wegen dem XP-Boosting.
Du willst einen LMG spielen
und ich bin ja normalerweise gar nicht
so dagegen,
wenn es wenig Waffen gibt.
Aber ein bisschen wenig ist es schon.
Du willst einen LMG spielen
und wirst erstmal in die tiefe Sinneskrise gestürzt.
Welche der vielen LMGs spiele ich denn jetzt?
Das erste LMG
oder das zweite LMG?
Was nehme ich denn jetzt?
Ich uninstall lieber.
In manchen Bereichen ist es doch schon ein bisschen wenig.
Aber da will ich mich gar nicht so sehr drüber aufregen.
Auch wenn man sich darüber aufregen kann.
Da können durchaus noch die ein oder anderen Sachen kommen.
Und ich fange jetzt auch gar nicht an,
weil das geht schon.
Alter, 27 Minuten meine Güte am Aufnehmen.
Ich fange jetzt auch gar nicht von dem UI an.
Das UI ist so dumm an vielen Stellen.
Waffenmenü.
Am Griff ist ein Plus,
aber kannst nicht draufklicken.
Auf der Map kannst du nicht richtig zoomen.
Man erkennt sich selbst kaum.
Alles ist mega umständlich im Menü.
Aber wie gesagt,
damit fange ich jetzt gar nicht an.
Aber zum Schluss kann ich sagen,
über viele Sachen habe ich mich gar nicht ausgelassen.
Bugs, fehlende Hitmarker, irgendwo reingeklitscht,
Respawn,
Revive-Bug,
alles mögliche.
Gestern haben wir uns mega kaputt gelacht im Stream.
Wir hatten jede Runde mindestens 5 teilweise Breaking-Bugs.
Das war so schlimm, dass es schon wieder lustig war.
Aber Bugs kann man beheben.
Den Kern nicht.
Und um den Kern des Games ging es mir in dem Video.
Ich habe sicherlich noch vieles vergessen.
Und ich sage euch jetzt wie es ist.
DICE bzw. EA, die da sicherlich nicht unschuldig dran sind,
wahrscheinlich die Hauptschuld sogar,
hat Battlefield mit diesem Game
und diesem Release zum Teil
selbst vernichtet.
Ich kann es nicht anders ausdrücken.
Und was können sie jetzt noch machen?
Es bleibt eigentlich nur eine Option.
Die müssen patchen wie verrückt.
Patchen, als gäbe es kein Morgen mehr.
Und Inhalte liefern.
Und das zackig. Und das schnell.
Und das richtig gute Inhalte.
Battlefield-Inhalte, die den Namen verdienen.
Spoiler, werden sie nicht hinkriegen.
Aber ernsthaft, wie realistisch ist das?
Ja, vielleicht machen sie das.
Aber wenn das denn wirklich mal kommt.
Wir wissen, dass DICE da auch nicht so schnell ist.
Vielleicht ist es diesmal besser.
Wenn wir Pech haben, kommt das.
Eventuell kommt das auch nicht.
Aber wenn es kommt, und zu spät kommt,
dann zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo das Game
keinen mehr richtig interessiert.
Ich habe mich jetzt zwar ziemlich heftig
über das Game ausgelassen, aber ich möchte jetzt
den letzten Satz noch mal loswerden.
Als richtig
Hardcore-Battlefield-Fanboy,
mein Battlefield-Herz
ist gebrochen.
Um es mal dramatisch zu sagen.
Ich werde natürlich trotzdem
ab und an spielen.
Keine Frage. Vor allem, weil ich gucken will,
wie sich das Ganze entwickelt.
Und das Spiel ja auch seine Momente hat.
Aber lange am Stück kann ich das nicht spielen.
Und ich habe auch nicht
riesen Hoffnung,
dass man an den absolut
grundlegenden Sachen, die ich hier angesprochen habe,
noch viel ändern wird.
Würde mich mal interessieren, was ihr zum Thema sagt.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss, Leute. Macht's gut.
Bis dann. See you.
So. Hallo, Leute. Hier ist der Max.
Ja, nein, nein. Noch mal müssen wir uns das Ganze jetzt nicht angucken.
Wenn ein Manager
es im Manager-Stream sieht... Ach, das juckt die doch
überhaupt nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich werde das Video in der Form wahrscheinlich auch
nicht hochladen.
Ja, das ist zu viel.
Also, wenn überhaupt, mache ich vorher
noch so einen Disclaimer. Ich habe mich manchmal ein bisschen
zu sehr
ausgelassen.
Mal gucken.
Und ich blende ein, dass das mit dem
Respawn überhaupt nicht mehr da ist.
Ah, ja. Wie fandet ihr das Gameplay im Hintergrund?
War doch teilweise richtig nice, oder?
Ging gut rein.
Natürlich ist es PPGA 29.
Aber was willst
du aktuell anderes spielen als in dem
Game? Entweder
bist du low level
und spielst irgendwas
oder du spielst PPGA
oder du bist ein höheres Level
und hast schon andere Waffen, die du spielen
kannst. Naja, geht
besser. Natürlich geht das besser.
Aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass ich
als 37-jähriger Boomer das Spiel
noch spiele, ist doch ganz okay.
Ja, MP9, die will ich freischalten. Ich brauche
nur noch ein Level oder so.
Denkst du, dass es überhaupt noch ein gutes Battlefield-Game
geben wird? Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich habe die Hoffnung nicht aufgegeben.
Hast du Halo reingeschaut? Nee, habe ich
untergeladen.
Aber schon.
Ich wollte zu irgendwas noch
sagen. Irgendwas mit kaufen oder so.
Kaufen?
Gekauft?
Best? Irgendeiner hat
geschrieben, ich würde mich nicht kaufen
lassen oder so. Oder was in der Richtung.
Irgendwas mit Influencer?
Ich finde das nicht mehr, das Comment.
Da wollte ich nämlich noch was zu sagen, weil ich das
ein ganz interessanter Punkt fand.
Ja, wie hieß denn dieses Comment?
Irgendeine Ahnung.
Oh, vielleicht hat der Edwublos davor
geschrieben. Video war jetzt
lang.
Recycle Story, Recycle Story.
Ach hier, das da.
Also,
mein Vorteil bei dieser Sache ist folgendes.
Schreibt mir das Neueste, was ich trotz EA Partner
schreibe. Ich bin ja nicht wirklich EA Partner.
Wir haben uns darauf geeinigt, dass wir hier ein bisschen
Sellout machen für Battlefield 2042.
Also, ich war mal im EA Partner
Programm, aber
als dann dieser,
ich glaube, das war
der Xbox-Skandal.
Ich glaube, das war der Xbox-Skandal.
Wo ein paar Influencer
Leute Werbung gemacht haben für die Xbox.
Inklusive
Briefing Papers und so, die geleakt sind
und die das nicht gekennzeichnet haben.
Dann haben damals viele Unternehmen
quasi ihre ganzen Partnerprogramme,
die nicht
mit Creators aus den USA waren,
abgebrochen.
Und das war damals auch. Aber seitdem habe ich
nie wieder bei irgendwie sowas in der Richtung mitgemacht.
Zumindest,
ehrlich gesagt, gibt jetzt auch
in Deutschland viele Content Creator, die das Game schön reden.
Das würde ich den Leuten
so pauschal gar nicht mal unterstellen.
Also, ich glaube,
die wahrscheinlichste Erklärung,
wenn jemand das Game schön redet, ist
nicht, dass er vom, also,
das was du hier schreibst, gibt es sicherlich auch.
Aber ich denke, wirklich,
und da bin ich mir, ich meine, ich kenne nicht
alle persönlich, aber da bin ich mir relativ sicher,
die meisten Leute reden sich das Game
nicht schön, weil
sie Geld von EA bekommen, sondern
die meisten Leute finden das Game entweder wirklich gut,
oder sie sind noch
nicht so weit, sich das einzugestehen,
dass es eigentlich ziemlicher Fail ist.
Eins von beiden.
Es gibt ja dieses Phänomen,
wenn man, das sind auch
so die Leute, die bei
Blizzard spielen,
übelst krass immer Fanboyen.
Ja?
Ich gucke ja manchmal Asmongold,
der sagt dazu immer, die Blizzard Dick Rider.
Das trifft's eigentlich ganz gut.
Das hast du
bei jedem Game, bei jeder größeren Serie,
bei jeder Firma. Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist,
ob die nicht vielleicht irgendwann mal
Fanboy des Monats gewinnen wollen, oder sonst was.
Und sobald
diese Leute sich dann eingestehen würden,
dass es doch nicht so gut ist,
das Spiel, dann
müssten sie sich ja selbst eingestehen,
sie haben jahrelang Schwachsinn gefanboyt.
So. Aber ich kann mir auch
durchaus vorstellen, dass von den
Content Creator wirklich
es durchaus
welche gibt, denen das Spiel
wirklich Spaß macht. Also das würde ich gar nicht
mal den Leuten so unterstellen, dass die alle gekauft sind
von EA. Das gibt's aber sicherlich auch.
Nein.
Blizzard hat nicht den letzten Fanboy verkrault.
Das ist doch genau das, was ich meine.
Das ist ein wunderbares Beispiel für das,
was ich meine.
was ich meine. Stell dir mal vor,
stell dir mal vor,
du warst ein
Blizzard Dick Rider die letzten Jahre über.
Also du hast wirklich Blizzard
gefanboyt bis zum Gehtnichtmehr.
Und jetzt kommt diese ganze Scheiße um
Blizzard und Activision raus.
Jetzt hast du die Wahl, dir einzugestehen,
fuck, was für einen Scheißladen
hab ich da eigentlich
quasi
hardcore gefanboyt.
Oder aber,
du kannst sagen, ach
Scheuklappen auf,
Blizzard beste, wow, beste,
bestes Spiel ever, jeder das Spiel
kritisiert ist ein Scheiß und jeder das Spiel
kritisiert hat, keine Ahnung, ich hasse jeden, der das Spiel kritisiert.
Und es ist
erstaunlich, wie viele Leute sich
für das Letztere entscheiden.
Weil sich selbst einzugestehen, dass vielleicht
nicht so sinnvoll war, was man
gemacht hat, hält
vielen Leuten unglaublich schwer.
Kennt glaube ich jeder.
Ist das gleiche,
wie damals Xbox und Playstation?
Xbox 360 oder
Playstation? Ich glaube jetzt
so mit ein bisschen Abstand,
sind sich glaube ich
alle
einig, die irgendwie nur ein bisschen
Verstand im Hirn haben und die Zeit
mitbekommen haben, dass der Online
Modus von der Xbox 360,
also Xbox Live mit den Partys und
alle möglichen, was es gab, einfach
besser war, als das PSN
auf der PS3. Es hat da auch was
gekostet und das nicht umsonst, also
das halt nicht unsinnigerweise,
sie haben damit schon was gemacht. Das war
einfach besser. Aber
diese Diskussionen damals
mit den Leuten,
du hattest dann halt welche,
die haben ihre Oma, Opa,
Mutter, Vater
drei Monate beschwätzt, dass sie
eine Playstation bekommen, weil sie Call of Duty
online spielen wollten. Oder was auch immer.
Witzigerweise war damals Call of Duty
schon das brutale Kinderspiel und
heute ist es immer noch. Wobei, die sind ein bisschen
älter geworden, darf man nicht dazu sagen.
Und ich habe mir da nicht
wenig auch von profitiert, muss ich
sagen. Und ich würde es auch heute noch spielen,
wenn, tja,
wenn es kein Skill-Best-Match-Banking gäbe.
Zumindest, die haben ihre
Verwandtschaft drei Monate genervt, bis sie dann
eine Playstation bekommen haben. Haben eine Playstation
gehabt, haben Call of Duty gespielt, haben festgestellt,
Fuck, Online-Modus der Playstation suckt.
So, was ist jetzt
das Beste?
Sich einzugestehen,
die Arbeit war komplett umsonst,
man hat 400 Euro in Sand
gesetzt, weil man nicht damit das machen kann, was
man will. Oder zu behaupten,
Playstation
beste Wixbox-Scheiße.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, was die meisten
Leute gemacht haben.
Und das ist so. Sich das einzugestehen,
da bricht für viele Leute so die Welt
zusammen und deswegen machen das nicht
so viele. Und deswegen gibt es heute auch
immer noch richtig viele krasse Blizzard-Fanboys.
Dafür kostenlos war Playstation
Network nicht so schlimm, das ist schon
richtig, aber
das gesamte Xbox Live war halt
konkurrenzlos besser.
Allein schon game-übergreifende
Voice-Chats und Partys.
Fuck it, here is the list of...
Okay, das müssen wir gucken.
Ach du...
Null!
Der will's aber wissen, das ist bestimmt noch nicht mal alles.
Was ist, was?
Einmal und ich sehe nichts.
Ja, morgen spielen wir auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Battlefield.
Weil dann sind die ganzen Noobs
am Start.
Ja ne, ich bin 10 Jahre älter.
Ich war mal, ich war, als ich Call of Duty Videos
gemacht habe, war ich in dem Alter.
Das ist, glaube ich, individuell unterschiedlich.
Mal kurz ein bisschen Doodle
anmachen.
Wir reden nur von der 360.
Die Xbox One ist Shit.
Xbox One ist richtige
Wixbox. Ja, genau.
Zockst du noch Venice?
Wo ist es denn?
Ich würde Venice spielen.
Das Problem bei Venice ist, Sekunde,
ich zeig das mal schnell.
Falls es überhaupt noch startet.
Ich zeig's mal ganz, ganz kurz.
Das Problem
an Venice ist,
es sieht etwas
düster aus, was Spielerzahlen
angeht.
Da ist nichts mehr.
Bisschen leer.
Ganz knapp.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Venice-Bot sogar besser,
als die Battlefield 2042-Bot.
Das ist ein Battlefield-3-Mod.
Naja, man kann es nicht so wirklich
Battlefield-3-Mod nennen.
Es ist Battlefield-3-Server
nachgebaut und
Battlefield-3-Client
erweitert.
Warum nicht?
Wenn dir das Spaß gemacht hat, ist doch gut.
Wirst du in Battlefield 2042 nicht haben,
weil es gibt ja da eigentlich nichts als Spielmodi.
In Portal gibt es, glaube ich, noch zusätzlich TDM.
Mit Scheiß-Spawns.
Noch schlechteren Spawns, als es eh schon gab.
So.
Wollen wir dann nochmal reingucken in diese Liste
mit allen Problemen.
Also mal ganz kurz.
Co-Features. No Singleplayer.
Ja. Standard Server-Browser.
Ja.
Standardized Game-Modes. Ja.
No Persistent Lobbies. Ja.
No Class-System. Ja.
Naja.
Ja. Es gibt kein Class-System.
In der alten Weise. Das ist richtig.
Battlefield ist nicht gut, aber
macht Spaß. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das gleiche
Battlefield 2042 spielen.
Aber das ist weder gut, noch
macht es mir Spaß. Aber wenn es dir Spaß macht,
ist es okay. Habe ich keine Schmerzen damit.
Best-Character-Customization.
Ja.
Profile-Progressions-Stats-Page. Habe ich in meinem ersten Video schon gesagt.
Ja. Battlelog-Stats. Ja.
Ja.
Da haben sie uns richtig krass gebetet mit den Doc-Tags.
Im Trailer hat man nämlich Doc-Tags gesehen.
Die haben eh
und eigentlich, wenn ich nicht so
krass gefanboyt hätte.
Ihr könnt euch vielleicht erinnern, wie ich ausgerastet bin.
Als sie das vorgestellt haben.
Hätte ich das durchschauen müssen.
Dass das einfach nur Trick ist.
Die haben Doc-Tags gezeigt.
Die haben aus Chat-Springen und
RPG gezeigt. Die coolen Sachen aus
Battlefield haben die gezeigt. Das war aber
eigentlich nur ein riesengroßer
G-Bait, um uns
quasi denken zu lassen, dass es ein
fertiges,
komplettes Battlefield ist.
Was sich wie ein
Battlefield spielt. Ist es aber nicht.
Es ist ein mitten aus der
Entwicklung gerissenes Spiel.
Was sowohl vom Kern her
nicht zu Ende gedacht ist, als auch in der Umsetzung
nicht fertig programmiert ist.
Ja. Ja. Ja.
Äh.
Was? No Cross-Game Profile
Screen. Was?
Echt? Ich kann mich noch an
Battlelog erinnern.
An Battlelog hattest du die Sachen
drinne. Aber für 1 und
5 gab es doch gar kein Battlelog, oder?
Ach, Stats. Ach so, vom Stats.
No Spectator. Ja.
Warum auch immer.
Permanent Community Server. Ja.
Richtig dumm. No Test Range.
Richtig dumm. Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf.
Das Spiel hat nicht mal
eine Test Range. Das Spiel hat
einen Modus gegen Bots, wo du Sachen
ausprobieren kannst. Ja, oder du kannst hier einen
Custom Portal Server aufmachen.
Aber,
ja, es gibt nicht mal eine Testing Range.
Kein Firing Range
oder so, wo du mal Waffen Recall
testen kannst, oder so.
Infanterie Gameplay.
Weniger Waffen. Korrekt. Weniger Infanterie. Ja.
Äh. Manual Leaning.
Da muss ich sagen,
das finde ich nicht schlimm.
Ich, ich weiß, dass
es in alten, ich glaube in Battlefield 2 gab's
gab's auch Leaning. Ich weiß, dass
dieses Leaning Feature in Battlefield 4
jetzt nicht super neu war.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich brauch's nicht unbedingt.
Also da hab ich jetzt persönlich wenig Probleme
mit. Ja, warum, das
versteh ich auch nicht, warum du nicht tauchen kannst.
Du kannst nicht gescheit springen. Ja, das
ist auch mega dumm.
Das war nämlich richtig cool in Battlefield 4,
wenn du über die Mauern springen
konntest. Aber das können Soldaten
2042 einfach nicht mehr. Die haben so viel
Hightech dabei, da klappt das nicht.
Äh. No Crouch Sprinting.
Ich kann mich gar nicht mehr richtig
dran erinnern. No
Backwards Prone.
Was meint der denn damit? Ah!
Dass der dann so schepp dalickt,
dass du besser in die Ecken konntest.
Stimmt, ja. Das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen.
No Explosion Knockback.
Das ist mir auch nicht aufgefallen.
No Rolling After Falling.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Das war in Battlefield 5, glaub, ne?
Mit dem, mit dem Abrollen.
Tatsächlich, ja. Aber das
find ich auch nicht schlimm, solang's. Dafür
killt's einen nicht so schnell. Äh.
No Ammo Health Pickups of
Teammates. Wie?
Moment.
Natürlich. Achso!
Der meint, dass man nicht hingehen kann zu nem Supporter
und sich das dem aus dem Rucksack nehmen kann.
Ja, das versteh ich auch nicht.
No Scope Zeroing.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, was
er meint. Wahrscheinlich, dass du dein
die, die, die, mit nem Sniper irgendwie
die Range einstellen kannst oder so.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht er aber äußerst
ins Detail. No Thermal Optics.
Das find ich jetzt persönlich nicht wild.
Thermal Optics durchgucken durch Smoke
war ne dumme Mechanik.
Oh, das ist jetzt, das ist subjektiv.
Suppression Mechanic. Oh, da bin ich froh,
dass es das nicht gibt. Es gibt kaum
Fahrzeuge, das ist richtig. Es gibt
eine? Ja, es gibt ne
Hovercraft, das gilt für alles.
Ja, die Anzeigen sind generell ziemlich pepega.
Oh, das find ich, das,
das find ich gut. Das find ich gut.
Ich, ich
hasse Aussteige- und Einsteige-Animationen.
Wobei's die ja gibt, teilweise.
Die können sich ja in dem Spiel nicht entscheiden.
Das Hovercraft, wenn du einsteigst,
hat eine Einsteige-Animation.
Manch andere Sachen haben das
nicht. Sogar das ist noch nicht mal konsistent.
Ja, generell sind die
Fahrzeuge sehr, wie sagt man so, so, so
up-, downgraded.
Auch was Attachments und sowas angeht.
In Battlefield 4 war das so ne Wissenschaft für sich.
Es ist sehr
langweilig. Zum Beispiel, dass es
keine TV-Mistel und sowas mehr gibt. Gibt's
2042 einfach nicht mehr.
Okay, das gucken wir uns das nicht alles an. Das ist ja
mega viel. Alter, das hört gar nicht auf.
Audio! Ganz ehrlich, das Audio ist
so im Arsch.
Ja. Das Audio ist
so im Arsch in diesem Game.
Du hörst Gegner, die
50 Meter weg sind, wie als wären sie
neben dir. Manchmal hörst du Gegner
neben dir gar nicht. Der Sound ist
so im Arsch. Das ist, kann ich
nicht. Und ich glaube, der Sound ist
das beste Beispiel für, dass
Battlefield 2042 aus
der Entwicklung, mitten aus der Entwicklung
gerissen wurde und released wurde.
Ups, oh.
Also, wenn der Sound nicht ein gutes
Beispiel dafür ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich glaube, es gibt,
gibt es irgendein Battlefield,
mal Heroes oder sowas
außen vor, das keinen
richtig geilen Sound hatte?
Mir fällt keins ein.
Selbst die Spiele, die ich nicht viel gespielt habe,
hatten einen richtig guten Sound.
Bad Company 1 Pogger Sound,
Bad Company 2 mit War Tapes Pogger Sound,
Bad Company, ähm, ich wollte gerade sagen
Bad Company 3, schön wär's.
Battlefield 3 Pogger Sound, Battlefield 4 Pogger Sound,
sogar auch, äh, richtig guter Sound,
obwohl es von einem anderen Studio gekommen ist.
Äh, 1 hat richtig, äh,
5, also das können die.
Also sagst du nicht kaufen, die halt auf gar keinen
Fall kaufen jetzt im aktuellen Zustand.
Ähm, und
ich glaube, daran sieht man wunderbar,
dass dieses Spiel einfach noch mitten in der Entwicklung
ist. Und man jetzt gesagt hat,
oh fuck, raus damit.
Ich, ich geh sogar so weit,
dass wenn die ein wirklich polished Game hätten
äh, rausbringen wollen, nächstes Jahr Weihnachten.
Äh, Less Impactful Soundtrack,
das Spiel hat keinen Soundtrack.
Also, doch, ich weiß, dass es nen
Soundtrack hat, aber es ist quasi ein nicht,
nicht existenter Soundtrack.
Es ist auch wieder so ein gutes, gutes, ähm,
äh,
ja, Indikator, für das es eben,
wie gesagt, mitten aus der Entwicklung,
äh, gerissen wurde. Was, was
auch witzig ist, die Specialist,
ja, das ist das riesen Ding, was sie angekündigt
haben für dieses Game.
Sie haben diesen, diesen Trailerfilm mit
Irish gemacht, es
gibt aber sonst,
so als wäre das auch noch mitten
in der Entwicklung, was, was Hintergründe,
Story und sowas angeht.
Das war's, also da ist nix
irgendwie
ausgearbeitet. Das ist alles
in so Konzept,
in so einer Konzeptstufe
noch irgendwie.
Das sieht man auch ganz gut auf der Battlefield
Webseite, zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung,
Battlefield 20 oder
nennen wir mal die.
So, die Specialists
haben bei denen auf der Webseite so eine,
Profilseite, wo man die sich angucken kann.
Was ich bis heute übrigens nicht verstanden habe,
ist warum die geschminkt in Krieg ziehen,
aber gut, kann jeder machen wie er will.
Ähm, aber es gibt Konzeptzeichnungen
zu diesem Game, aber mehr
anscheinend irgendwie auch nicht. Also sprich,
da sollte wohl wirklich so eine Art
Geschichte
erzählt werden oder
das irgendwie noch stimmiger einbinden,
aber das ist alles so in der,
in der Konzeptphase irgendwie.
Das Spiel ist einfach nur halb,
halb durchdacht
und halb fertig programmiert.
Daran sieht man das, denke ich, auch ganz
schön. Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich so ist. Das Spiel war doch
mehr oder weniger nach Release schon
dead. Ich weiß, es sind, es hat ein bisschen
Comeback gehabt. Ich weiß nicht,
ob es sich das Game überhaupt gibt.
Ich, äh,
könnte mir vorstellen, so
masochistisch ist er nicht.
Ich denke, das denke ich auch.
Das würde auch dafür sprechen, ich meine,
hier, die haben, die haben ja tatsächlich
ganz coole
Konzeptbilder und so, also was heißt, was, wie nennt man
sowas? Es ist ja nicht wirklich ein Konzeptbild,
es ist so ein,
so Background, Background
ähm, Art-Dings,
um das, quasi die Welt
und die Story ein bisschen auszuschmücken.
Und jetzt sind außer doofe Sprüche
in den Menüs nix vor, nix übrig
geblieben. Ah ja, okay.
Kann man später noch Waffen
in Portal leveln? Wurde dazu was gesagt? Ja, theoretisch,
theoretisch hättest du in Portal
wunderbar leveln können. Ach nee,
du meinst, ob du, ob du quasi Waffen
anlocken kannst und sowas.
Nö, das, das weiß man nicht,
was da noch reinkommt. Ich vermute ja mal,
wenn das Spiel, ähm, floppt,
wovon ich aktuell mal ausgehe,
wird's da leider nicht mehr so viel
geben.
Ist Portal auch im Arsch? Ja,
Portal ist auch im Arsch.
Unkaputtbare Drohne in Bad Company 2
zum Beispiel, Revive Bug, der
in Portal viel öfters auftritt.
Ja.
Ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Game ist ja auch Müll.
Hast du den auch, äh, ja,
ich hab am Anfang überhaupt gar nichts
getroffen. Jetzt hab ich mich ein bisschen
dran gewöhnt, aber man hat's ja hier in dem Video auch
öfters gesehen.
Natürlich kommt da mein Alter dazu,
aber es ist schon ganz schön Scheibenwischer zwischendurch.
Und das liegt, das liegt nicht nur,
nicht nur an mir.
Dass das, dass das so
Scheibenwischer ist teilweise.
Es ist sehr, sehr merkwürdig
in dem Game. Und ich hab schon fast
alles eingestellt, was es einzustellen gibt.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich auch daran, dass es wenig
FPS sind. 90 FPS
ist für das Spiel schon viel, ich weiß, aber es sind
insgesamt trotzdem nicht so viel. Ähm,
und dass die so inkonsistent sind.
Ne, ganz ehrlich,
SBMM kommt mir nicht
in die Tüte. Da reg ich mich ja nur noch
mehr auf.
Und das ist blutdrucktechnisch nicht gut.
Sonst muss ich doch irgendwann Blutdruck-Tabletten
oder so nehmen. Das müsste man eigentlich,
eigentlich bräuchten wir als GIF,
wenn ich mich mal wieder aufrege,
eigentlich bräuchten wir als GIF hier irgendwie sowas
als Blutdruck, Blutdruck, ähm,
Blood Pressure
Animation
Ne, äh, äh, Monitor heißt
es glaub ich, ne?
Monitor Animation GIF.
Seht was? Irgendwas Gutes, das wir
als GIF reinmachen könnten.
Ne, ist alles keine Animation.
Type
GIF
Oh, das ist 1995,
alter, die Animation.
Ja, wenn das jetzt eine Animation wäre, wäre gut gewesen.
Ah ja.
Jaja, hab ich alles schon gemacht.
Ich hab alles schon eingestellt,
was man einstellen kann in dem Game.
Aber trotzdem, und ich glaube es ist halt einfach
wegen den inkonsistenten und generell
sehr niedrigen FPS, dass es sich
merkwürdig anfühlt.
Es sind Releases dieses Jahr, also das neue Halo,
was, alles was ich davon
bis jetzt gehört hab, soll das
wirklich, also Multiplayer, ähm,
soll das sehr nice sein.
Und wisst ihr was übelst Bock macht, aber
ich hab erst damit angefangen,
äh,
weiß ich, ob das Spiel jemand hat,
das ist jetzt
nix für ein Stream oder nix für Videos
oder so, aber zum Entspannen nebenbei
ist das super. Ich hab erst damit angefangen, aber das macht
mega Bock. Also wer so,
wer sowas wie Theme Park
oder, oder Rollercoaster Tycoon
oder sowas mochte, wobei es ein bisschen
in die andere, nicht exakt in diese
Richtung geht, aber schon ungefähr in die Richtung,
ähm,
kann ich das hier echt nur empfehlen. Es macht mega Bock.
Ist aber halt
auch kein krasses Triple-A
Game mit, äh,
200 Millionen Kosten.
Boah.
Leiseres Game, also das macht wirklich Spaß.
Ist das Game Homeoffice-tauglich?
Was verstehst du da drunter?
Du meinst, dass du schnell wegtappen kannst,
wenn dich einer anruft oder was?
Ja, das kannst du machen. Ne, aber was, was meinst du?
Wann ist für dich ein Game
Homeoffice-tauglich? Also was, was für Kriterien
muss das Game erfüllen, dass es Homeoffice-tauglich
ist? Ich darf jetzt nichts Falsches sagen.
Weil ich weiß, dass mein Chef manchmal im
Stream reinguckt. Ach, man muss
zwischendurch pausieren können.
Ja. Das kannst
du machen. Das ist nicht
always on.
Und online permanent gesunken.
Jaja, du kannst, kannst, kannst pausieren,
kannst sogar weitermachen dann.
Moin Max, würdest du aber
als Rechner im Produktiv-Einsatz, die
noch auf Windows 7 laufen, zum jetzigen Teil auf Windows 10
und direkt auf Windows 11. Äh, jetzt
aktuell würde ich noch Windows 10 nehmen.
Windows 11 hat auch so
einige Kinderkrankheiten, beispielsweise,
dass Drucker mal wieder kaputt sind.
Ist ja auch so ein Ding. Ich weiß nicht, was
es mit Microsoft und Druckern auf sich hat.
Aber Microsoft und Drucker
verträgt sich nicht so gut.
Gab ja einige Probleme in den letzten Monaten.
Aber ansonsten, ich bin
echt kein guter Berater, was Windows
angeht. Würdest du mich fragen, sollen wir
auf Linux updaten? Dann würde ich sagen,
nein. Würde ich auch nicht empfehlen. Aber damit
könnte ich euch wenigstens helfen.
Linux und Drucker ist auch Painschamp. Das
kommt drauf an. Das kommt
drauf an, wenn es ein Netzwerkdrucker ist und
quasi alles dabei ist, dann ist es easy as fuck.
Wenn es ein USB-Drucker ist und
alles dabei ist, auch easy as fuck.
Wenn nicht alles dabei ist
oder wenn es ein Multifunktionsgerät ist, was nicht
gut unterstützt wird, dann ist
es tatsächlich äußerst
Painschamp.
Kennst du einen guten Drucker für Linux?
Kann ich dir keinen empfehlen, weil
meiner geht zwar gut,
aber der ist alt und
den würde ich nicht empfehlen.
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Mails
nebenbei gucken, weil
ich werde demnächst
nochmal Sellout machen. Nicht nur
diese EA-Geschichte.
Ich habe auch ein
äh, muss jetzt überlegen,
was ich sagen darf.
Ich habe auch ein
Placement mit
Wargaming.
Aber nicht World of Tanks und nicht
World of Warships.
Da habe ich gesagt, das mache ich nicht.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber nur Videoclip.
Nichts langes.
Ich habe jetzt gesehen, auch bei mir an den
Statistiken, dass das
nee, nee, nee, nee,
auch nicht World of
Warplanes, falls es das überhaupt gibt.
Gibt es das?
Nein, nein, das ist für etwas anderes.
Und
ich habe jetzt auch gesehen, anhand
der Statistiken bei mir, dass
das eigentlich ganz gut
ankommt. Wenn ich Hetzenerwerbung mache,
kein Problem. Wenn ich jetzt diese
EA-Placement mache, kein Problem.
Ich sehe das in den Statistiken,
dass die Leute die Werbung skippen.
Aber, ich glaube,
über 60% gucken
die Werbung auch. Also,
ist für euch für alle gut.
Deswegen mache ich das ja auch nicht so lange. Maximal 60 Sekunden.
Nein, auch nicht War Thunder.
Fassende Badge-Musik, hä?
Tja, wer weiß.
Was ist mit Battlefield Mobile?
Gibt es das? Stimmt, das
gibt es. Was weiß ich?
Nein, das
könnt ihr nicht sehen, dass ihr skippt.
Das wissen die aber, dass viele Leute skippen.
Doch, kein Ding.
Ja, genau, ich mache noch.
Hey Leute, ich habe heute zufällig, als ich
im Rewe war, dieses neue Spiel
gefunden.
Genau, so machen wir das.
Und das ist so toll.
Das muss ich euch einfach zeigen.
Ich bin jetzt auch
der Coin Master übrigens.
Moment, gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Zack.
Das ist so 4,5
Sterne.
Das erweckt ja den Anschein,
als taugt dieses Spiel was.
Aber Mobile Gaming,
Alter, Mobile Gaming. Aha, Anfang ist ein super Spiel.
Der hat keine technischen
Schwierigkeiten. Der will einfach nicht
20.000 Euro bei eurem Game ausgeben.
Mobile Gamer. Mobile Gamer
sind einfach
der Abschaum.
Mobile Games und Mobile Gamer,
wobei ich hauptsächlich sagen würde,
Mobile Gamer,
Casual Mobile Gamer,
weil es gibt die ein oder anderen ganz guten Mobile Games
und Leute, die das spielen, die natürlich nicht.
Aber die meisten Mobile Gamer
ist echt...
Die sind ja mit dran schuld, dass es diesen Kack überhaupt gibt.
Weil die das mitmachen
und dicke Geld reinbuttern.
Gamer ist mir universell genug.
Mit Sicherheit,
mit Sicherheit.
Garantiert.
NFT Games sind voll angesagt
aktuell und die gibt es bestimmt.
Hundertprozentig Mobile schon.
Mir fällt jetzt keins ein,
aber die gibt es 100 pro.
Das ist so angesagt.
NFT Games sind ja gerade
der richtige Trend.
So von Pixel Games
bis
diese Spiele,
die virtuelles Land verkaufen
für Games, die nicht mal existieren.
Ihr fragt euch jetzt bestimmt, wer kann sowas
bescheuertes denn machen?
Wer ist noch bescheuerter
und kauft das? Das gibt es.
Das gibt es.
Es gibt Games, die verkaufen quasi
virtuelle, virtuelles Land
auf einer virtuellen Erde,
zu der kein Spiel existiert,
aber sie besitzen Land auf einer
virtuellen Erde, womit sie
niemals was anfangen können für tausende Euro.
Es ist einfach,
also es gibt Sachen,
ich bin ja da eigentlich ganz gut
drin so mit dem
also halbwegs Schritt halten mit der Zeit
und den Entwicklungen, ja, aber
das sind so Sachen, die verstehe ich nicht.
Die kann ich nicht verstehen,
aber da bin ich beruhigt, weil ich weiß,
dass es viele Leute, die jetzt jung sind,
die verstehen das auch nicht.
Earth2 zum Beispiel.
Earth2 ist nicht das einzige,
das ist jetzt aber auch das erste, was mir einfällt,
aber ist bei weitem nicht das einzige.
NFTs, ganz ehrlich, ich habe den,
also ich habe weder bisher genau verstanden,
wo ein NFT anfängt
und wo ein NFT aufhört,
aber ich glaube, das weiß keiner so genau,
weil wirklich gehören tut ihr das nicht.
Zum Beispiel,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr davon noch gar nichts gehört,
aber ich versuche das mal so kurz grob zu umschreiben.
Also, du kannst dir beispielsweise
den ersten Tweet
auf Twitter,
den kannst du kaufen.
Dann hast du eine Website, da steht drauf,
dir gehört
der erste Tweet,
was ja gar nicht stimmt,
weil der erste Tweet ist nach wie vor auf Twitter gehostet
und du hast da absolut keinen Einfluss drauf.
Eigentlich
kaufst du dir bloß eine Namensplakette
quasi
auf einer
Third-Party-Seite
unter diesem
Tweet, wo draufsteht,
dass der dir gehört.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, also
ich weiß nicht, ob es jemand gibt,
der das wirklich checkt.
Äh
Ich habe es
bis heute nicht genau verstanden.
Ja, super.
Genau. Ja, das ist ja schön und gut.
Ihr gehört das Bild, welches in der Blockchain
eingeladen ist.
Das ist ja schön und gut.
Aber dir gehört ja trotzdem nicht der erste Tweet.
Der ist ja nach wie vor auf Twitter.
Das ist ungefähr so.
Gibt es da irgendwie
ein Real-Life,
Real-World-Beispiel für,
keine Ahnung,
wenn du dir eine Namensplakette kaufst
von,
keine Ahnung, du gehst ins Museum
und du bezahlst
den Geld, dass deine Namensplakette quasi
nur in einem Bild steht oder sowas.
Also ich check diese ganzen Sachen
nicht richtig.
Ja, natürlich können sie das.
Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem mit, dass sie das machen.
Ich verstehe es nur nicht.
Oh, Metaverse, genau, das gibt es auch noch, ja.
Ja, sowas zum Beispiel.
Davon könnte es ein NFT
geben.
Das erste Comet im Linux Kernel Repo.
Aber trotzdem gehört dir das nicht.
Es ist sehr merkwürdig.
Es ist äußerst, äußerst
merkwürdiges Phänomen.
Ja, habe ich doch gerade erklärt.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man sich das kauft.
Also was der Reiz daran ist,
die quasi
die Namensplakette an einem,
an einer Verknüpfung
oder eines Bildes
vom ersten Tweet
zu kaufen.
Das gibt es bestimmt schon.
Es gibt bestimmt Leute,
die haben ihren
Fußzeh oder so fotografiert
als NFT.
Aber es gibt alles bestimmt schon.
Ja, das war das Linux Desktop.
Ja, nächstes Jahr ist es soweit.
Und wisst ihr,
wem wir das zu verdanken haben?
Wahrscheinlich Microsoft.
So doof es klingt.
Und Linux auf dem Desktop wird nicht
Linux auf dem Desktop sein,
sondern für Windows mit WSL.
Und ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
WinGL?
Nee, wie heißt das?
Nee, nicht.
WSL?
WSLG?
Ja, genau.
Das wird das Jahr des Linux Desktops.
Es hätte man sich auch nicht gedacht,
vor
sagen wir mal vor 10 Jahren
oder als der Ballmer noch am Start war,
der mit Stühlen nach Leuten geworfen hat
im Gang,
weil sie zu Google wechseln.
Da gibt es ja diese Story,
dass irgendjemand gesagt hat bei Microsoft,
er kündigt, er geht zu Google
und dann muss der Ballmer ihm quasi
den Stuhl durchs Fenster geworfen haben.
Der Kerl war auch durch.
Also durch die Scheibe.
Also er muss ihm den Stuhl hinterher geworfen haben,
dass der Stuhl durch die Scheibe geflogen ist.
Also weiß auch nicht,
was da bei Microsoft los gewesen ist.
Aber damals hätte glaube ich keiner gedacht,
dass man Microsoft dafür verantwortlich ist,
dass 2022
das Jahr des Linux Desktops wird.
Nein, nein, du kaufst hier kein Copyright.
Der Tweet ist nach wie vor auf Twitter
und Twitter hat die Rechte an diesem Tweet.
Twitter könnte
sogar diesen Tweet löschen.
Mich wundert nix mehr.
Mich wundert echt nix mehr.
Das schöne daran ist, als NFT verkauft
heißt, er hat ihn immer noch
und kann ihn zu allem benutzen,
wozu man ihn so braucht.
Eigentlich
hat das überhaupt keine Auswirkung
auf ihn, dass er die verkauft hat per NFT.
Das ist die Frage,
ob KVM geht.
Da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Aber nachdem das neue
WSL ja auch nur eine VM ist,
da müssen wir nested Virtualisierung an.
Es könnte vielleicht sogar KVM gehen.
Also in WSL 1
geht KVM garantiert nicht.
Aber in WSL 2
könnte das funktionieren.
Warum wird das nächste Jahr ein Jahr des Linux Desktops?
Ja, das ist ja nur so halb ernst gemeint.
Es wird das Jahr des Linux Desktops,
weil WSL
und WSLG, also sprich
das Linux, was
das
Linux für Windows von Microsoft,
also das, was unter Windows läuft,
weil das mittlerweile
relativ gut ist und
mittlerweile mit WSLG auch grafische Programme
kann und das Ganze relativ
zackig.
Und deswegen könnte man sagen,
es ist das Jahr des Linux Desktops,
weil viele Leute diesen Kram halt eben unter
ihrem Windows auf dem Desktop verwenden werden.
Ja, Developers, Developers,
beste,
legendäre Typ hier.
Der ist auch durch.
Der ist auch komplett durch
gewesen. Der hat ja mittlerweile glaube ich
ein Baseball- oder Basketball-Team
und geht da wohl am Rand manchmal auch so ab.
Das scheint,
das scheint ihm so im Blut zu liegen.
Vielleicht sollte ich auch mal was von
mir als NFT anbieten.
Irgendwas hat ja eh keine
Auswirkungen. Was weiß ich,
der Original,
der Original Max-Kicks-Avatar oder so.
Aber natürlich nicht die Rechte da dran, sondern
einfach nur, dass man sein Namensplakette dagegen
kriegt. Ich weiß, dass ich das machen kann.
Ich kenn die Seiten schon.
Aber das ist dann
easy, easy, easy money.
Augenbraue. Ja, ich biete einfach meine
Augenbraue als NFT an. Das heißt ja nicht, dass ich
die Augenbraue irgendwie wirklich jemandem geben müsste.
IP-Adresse als NFT.
NFT.
Es wird Zeit für den NFT-Champ
würde ich sagen, oder?
Ich hab zwar keine Ahnung, was ich da mache,
aber die meisten, die damit was zu tun
haben ja auch nicht.
Das ist ja nicht so viel als NFT.
Nee, da müsste ich ja was machen für.
Mit Sicherheit. 100 pro.
Du gehst auf die Seiten, wo du NFTs
anbietest und klickst das da durch.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht. Keine Ahnung, wie das
im Detail funktioniert.
Ich glaube, ich kann das Video jetzt löschen.
Warum?
Ah, weil ich es hier noch auf habe.
Wobei, ich kann es auch da lassen.
Leute, ich habe es gesehen.
Schon spät.
Was für ein Video war das?
Das war das Battlefield-Video, was wir uns gerade angeguckt haben.
Was ich nicht auf YouTube hochladen wollte.
Geiler Fahrstuhl.
Zack.
Gucken wir mal.
Was, kommen da jetzt 60 Leute raus, oder was?
Nice.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein scheiß Map-Design?
Wenn ich sowas schon sehe, kriege ich Anfälle.
Und ja, ich weiß, es ist nicht der einzige Fahrstuhl.
Im anderen Gebäude gibt es auch noch welche.
Ich glaube, hier hinten gibt es auch noch einen.
Aber was für eine bescheuerte Idee überhaupt, sowas zu machen.
Krass, Alter.
Maximale 13 Personen.
Ja, morgen letzter Arbeitstag für dieses Jahr.
Pock.
So, aber Leute, es ist soweit.
Schon spät.
Müde.
Also.
Gerade eingeschaltet.
Ja, ich gehe jetzt aber trotzdem off.
Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen direkt wieder.
In der Hoffnung,
das Spiel hat kein Skill-Based Matchmaking.
Und wir können Loops bashen.
Alles klar, bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.
Kriegen wir das Wort?
Ich mache ein Wort-NFT einfach.
Easy.
Bis dann.